all right and we are live the last word
with lord cognito ibontas thai guy
travis and some illustrious
guests at the destiny care fight and i
cannot wait to talk to you before we get
into all of that let's start with the
cheetah himself ibontes how are we doing
sir doing good spent a lot of time in
the dungeon this weekend and also got a
puppy not really a puppy we rescued um
but what did you do in destiny yeah
i can't
i can't i can't wait
i played a lot of the dungeon try little
iron banner i got a dog so i now have
three huskies inside of my house so some
people probably consider me a little
crazy uh but we rescued him he's
not even a year old he still definitely
has some more puffiness to him um so
he's been handful and
yeah that's been a lot of it but we have
some guests coming so i don't want to
take too much time so travis what about
you
uh yeah i'm doing games coverage i'm
reviewing a game called
mario striker's battle arena for uh for
ign doing uh
some previews had a few previews go live
and since the last time we talked
destroy all humans too re-probed
classic uh
classic repro
re-probed yeah no not remastered they
went up your butt twice
um yeah
it's a game about aliens so it's it's on
brand okay
yeah so just you know and also
spending time in in both my uh earthly
dungeons and also my digital dungeons
and destiny so
um lots of lots of good times to be had
inside destiny these days everybody
would go touch the earthly dungeon
shirt certainly did
he's my master i can't we
trapped gonna be an interesting one
everybody and we're not even halfway
through so yeah
yeah what about you man it's good just
been bouncing around man so much going
on we got shows we got the playstation
just did a statement
it's gonna be nuts we got prediction
shows all this type of stuff going on so
it's absolutely crazy for me but i did
not want to miss this and uh teddy knows
my secret i was scrambling last minute
i've been so busy i didn't get a chance
to touch the dungeon until today that i
literally was scrambling to the last
second but yeah we'll talk let's talk
with tough but we got some some cool
guests bae
yeah well i'm gonna do a little
a little group intro here so gonna be
anything too crazy not maybe crazy a
little off the cuff just you know so
here we go wow welcome to the last word
episode 201 for those of you astute or
calling me out 200 is gonna be at a
different date so we're saving that one
for later so this is 200 201 you guys
figure out what you want to call it but
it'll be labeled 201 that being said uh
the dungeon is here iron banner is very
divisive and the sparks are flying all
over the place that being said we are
joined by some amazing guests this
evening to have quite a discussion about
kind of the different different hot
takes of the world of destiny right now
so one of our guests this evening is a
usual supporter of a tin foil hat and
has one of the
widest smiles that you've ever seen he
will light up an entire room
another man just got back from vacation
coming in hot off of the jet lag with
the amazing locks always looking very
very well taken care of but also enjoy
shredding on the guitar if you listen to
them and then finally the man with more
technology retro rigs and monitors and
cables and everything else in his room
there is no question there are 14 fire
hazards behind him on screen much less
anything else
so let's welcome cb gray scaro9 and
teasing teddy all returning to the
campfire welcome everybody how are we
doing
yo doing great thanks for having us on
howdy howdy yeah
absolutely families in the building i
feel like these are like the og's for
like last word like i feel like these
are like the ones that really got us
jumping off each on an individual level
like real talk cb gotta salute you man i
love to see your journey man it's so
cool to see what you're doing and on a
personal level i love that you're doing
better so the salute to you scarole
that's my brother we always we always
have a friendly little sparrow but i
love it i love what he's doing the
content is amazing and the boy can rip
on the guitar i still think the one that
you did for for riven was just
outstanding i love that
teddy yeah teddy that homie you already
know my warlock brother my tech brother
if i see if i'm on destiny and it's like
3 one i see teddy i know i'm going too
late but i can't i was like all right i
gotta talk to him because i'm all too
late but it's like yo we gotta tell what
you talking about i'm a salute to all of
y'all for coming do i just want to give
y'all y'all love for pulling up at the
campfire yeah thanks for having us yeah
on the flip side too congrats on the big
200. oh my goodness that's all that's a
lot to do anything 200 times is super
impressive so just congrats on the grind
and keep it up y'all yeah
i take full credit for all 200 episodes
and travis has been a wonderful addition
to the show yeah i'd also like to state
as a counterpoint that uh i don't like
any of our guests
i just i feel like sometimes you get too
much love so i'll just be the i'll be
the counterweight to that and i'll just
say yeah me neither really
[Music]
when you say something and it says like
they'll remember that i'll remember that
i'm pretty sure i'm gonna be sharing a
room with teddy in uh t-minus seven days
so yeah the hotel room i mean oh yeah
yeah yeah let's give it away are we
gonna be there
i'll be there i'll meet you i'll be
there scared you're gonna be there where
ccx you've gone no no not this year not
for me you just got back from your first
generation right just got back from it
was really funny because i was like
when we were planning it uh you know
because we originally had tickets for
you know pre-pandemic and they carried
over or whatever and i was talking with
my wife and uh we decided this year you
know florida and restrictions and stuff
and yeah with
me going into
the final year my phd i don't want to
take any chances i was like yeah florida
and then
this concert or this festival came up in
malta and it was like we're just going i
was like well some people are gonna
think that's a little bit hypocritical
but
the eu has way stronger restrictions for
this [ __ ] so yeah dude yeah
you have to be vaccinated you have to
get negative tests to enter countries
and stuff wow way way better way better
we did and one vacation to
we took a trip to barbados like last
year as well and same thing it's like
you notice everybody else takes this
away more seriously than we do
if you go other places if you're coming
back you're like oh i got to take a test
just to get out of the hotel room but
flying into the united states it's kind
of like um do i do i need to do anything
nope just come on
yeah the only requirement for us for the
united states is now you have to have a
negative test within 24 hours of your
flight back
we flew the only airline that still
requires masks and stuff and it's like
so it was just a little bit i think for
us and our
comfort zone and you know our loved ones
and stuff that was just kind of the
right move but next year i hope everyone
enjoys it i hope you guys are going to
have a great time i'll be
on twitter being all jealous but next
year uh
you know yeah i'll be there for sure for
sure no doubt
what's going on in this game what's
going on yeah so since the podcast
happened
last week which was just us kind of at
the start of the season
um
things happened over the weekend on
friday we had the dungeon launch which i
know scarra jumped into live after his
trip i still don't know you might have
been a little delirious but that's fine
um we also got iron banner we've got
rift back in the game and before we get
to those i wanted to get the initial
impressions of the season from our guest
like where are you at with regards to
seasonal
activity um not the dungeon yet not iron
banner about the seasonal activity how's
the story treating you guys how's the
season of the haunted coming out of the
shoot for kind of first week and a half
for you
teddy you can go first if you want to
you've always got an interesting
take
um
i don't like it
but i don't want to be super i don't
want to be super debbie downer so
like i think the story is fantastic i
think they've really nailed that formula
now at this point
um but i'm kind of over the leviathan
and i i just don't
care for it
um
and the event itself will
cool like the first time is kind of
whatever after travis is lovely you know
the same time
uh at least the rewards are good so
that's that's a plus these public event
type of stuff tend to have kind of not
great like not a great loot chase so
that's the tldr uh again i don't want to
be super debbie downer so i'm enjoying
it for what it is well by facial
expression counterpoint scaro
[Laughter]
uh every the opposite of everything yeah
like so the loot's great
so he thinks salute is bad
uh as as a metal head this season the
aesthetic is like
just freaking perfect you know just
perfect a great job to everyone on the
design team for all of that um i'm not
sick of the leviathan i miss my daddy
kalas a lot
the the leviathan raids uh they just i
don't know i like all the raids maybe
not vog but i like all the other aids
see he was doing so well and then
um
no he's gotta get he's gotta get that
job
you know
good
uh but just like oh man it's
the leviathan aesthetic has always been
like my favorite like anytime you look
up my character in the game i'm i'm just
some gold looking ass running around
every time that's just me you know
and you combine that with a metal
aesthetic and it's just like oh my god
dude it's perfect um the yeah the public
event castlem thing is fine the seasonal
activities are never like
the best you know whatever
the the weekly story mission the sever
mission they're they're cool they are
what they are
um
but from a seasonal standpoint i love
where the story is going
i can't wait to see where it goes and uh
just overall theme and aesthetic of this
season i i it is
10 out of 10 for me so
very high very high cb cray
sir so i'm somewhere i'm somewhere
blended okay so so which is actually
kind of nice because i guess we're
hearing both contrasts so i'm kind of
like so first off the start about what i
love loot is great like i definitely
like the loot too i like the chase i
mean i've grinded a bunch and i still
barely have any reds which i kind of
like i kind of like like those grinds it
kind of like makes me miss like the days
of like grinding like you know ep
shotguns and things that just never drop
you're just grinding your head and stuff
for stuff to drop like i kind of like
weirdly like that stuff i love going
back to leviathan my actual my favorite
raid is fire stars so just like mascara
said going back
is also very very nice and with that
being said the aesthetic is very very
nice too
huge respect for that by the way it is
is
[Music]
have you played any other raids aside
from stars
every single one
yes
okay
with that being said though with that
being said i mean in general war mind i
just think doesn't get the credit
deserves for what i did to the game
people people don't realize what
forsaken did with the whisper with
everything that it did to set up
forsaken it was the alley of that love
first i would agree with that we can get
that we can get into that in a different
day i'm not gonna let you ride off the
inspire we'll let you finish your
thought but we're gonna call out to this
box
i love water glass i love you brother i
love you guys
so lastly though all i was going to say
is with me the one thing that i'm hoping
that's like it's left for me to be
desired is the story is great um i like
the public event for what it is and
sever for what it is but i'm hoping that
they expand where we're not just always
and sever going to gauntlet in the
public event only being dogs and bath i
would love to see it expand to drain the
armory the the conduit uh leviathan's
just so vast and it just feels like we
really only got a tiny little portion of
it so i'm hoping that over the season
things evolve or else i feel like it's
going to be stagnant like i would hope
not to be in august still running around
in the dog room or in severus still in
castellam that's gonna
you know i'm just that that's the part
for me i i'm hoping that we see some
evolution in maybe zavala story or
titles
i bet containment will stay the same but
sever i bet like we haven't seen
anything with the outside of the level
leviathan yet i bet like titles
because it's like pretty obvious it's
gonna be her in and gaul right and i bet
that that scene i can just see it set on
like the old entrance for the leviathan
on the gold bridge and you're just like
looking out over the moon or whatever
like that's like perfect i bet that's
what it's probably exactly so well i was
going to say from the trailer there was
one like the portal in the gauntlet room
where you jump in to the ring
like to face him
that same looking portal is in the loot
room of the old og leviathan raid like
where all the callus robots are on
either side yeah yeah sure exactly
that's why i was like i'm wondering like
first two seem to be with like gauntlet
hopefully yes
so that's that's what i'm praying with
if we're in loot room for title awesome
and then maybe zavala if we're in i mean
uh anywhere else it could be anywhere it
could be outside like scaroa said it
could be and conduit it could be the
fans remember the fans area it could be
just the fish just just expand leviathan
right now it feels small to me yeah it i
i like one it's just it's a super small
thing but usually what bungie does when
they do these seasonal rotations they'll
do like mission one two three augmented
mission one two three yeah but this time
it's really cool with crow like crow it
wasn't crows of volatile crows of
violence of all like
that's cool as well it i don't know it
had more short-term finality to these
storylines which i i think serves the
season's narrative well uh but we'll see
how that change you know we still have
four weeks at least of narrative
probably five but we'll see so yeah i
think there's seven steps to the quest
so we've got probably two two and two
and then yeah
like a combination one yeah yeah yeah
well so that was kind of the impressions
on the first week uh i wanted to kind of
get hey what about you guys
like for me i'm
probably somewhere in the in between as
well i go
when you log in at first you're like
cool running around doing nightmare
content awesome sever you got to see
crow and you're like oh
that's all we get and it's kind of that
like you get the realization of like hey
it's cool to have something that we
haven't even seen in a while but it's
also
especially this week when nightmare
containment didn't move which i had very
minimal expectations but i wish it would
actually change locations but no other
location is set up for it i'm not too
surprised about that one it's just a
different boss sitting in the same spot
so that's like
it's fine it's there um
and then like if you go through and you
get all the triumphs in the other areas
by finding all the bosses which doesn't
take that long
you kind of realize there's not going to
be that much more reason to explore so
then you realize if you want to start
grinding out your reputation you want to
grind out the guns the opulent frames
all of that type of stuff you realize it
is going to be a whole lot of the same
so when that kind of sets in
you're like your grade kind of goes
a little bit down um but then i mean you
get like offstringer you get some of the
new weapons and stuff they look pretty
cool so it's kind of as you guys said
the loot's good location's a little
different we'll get to the dungeon here
in a minute which definitely kind of
gives a little bit of
change to the overall feel but as i see
because the dungeon technically you can
buy that thing separate if you don't buy
the season season of the haunted and of
itself story very curious to see where
it goes i'm going to guess that we're
going to go
sorry i have a dog i have to watch him
in here crow um then we're probably
going to go zavala because we don't know
anything about scythe
right or sayed i forget the name and
then i'm guessing the culmination
logically for would be title so yeah
that's my guess of the six
so overall it's been
interesting but it also feels like it
could turn into one of those because
we're not gonna get like a raid and then
a master raid we're not gonna get we
we've kind of seen ever it's gonna it
could turn into a tuesday game
if you're playing other stuff it could
do that so it's just it has
if you guys are listening to this on
audio
dog has rope and just like whipping it
around everywhere so yeah
dog doesn't like the season
i'll jump right quick yeah i'm in the
middle i think um i see where teddy's
going which is the long-term
thing and you know being kind of like a
glorified public event on some level but
i am with scare i love the leviathan
aesthetics so much that i am still a
victim of nostalgia i still am a victim
of the opulence the goldness and all the
callous sayings and the lore and i
really do want to know more about them i
know we'll get into the dungeon and talk
about that but the the crow story i
thought was really good you know they
really try to expand and give them some
finale i i was surprised to see a part
two to it to be honest and move him
along and get it going because that's
the only thing with him like travis
being you've talked about it it's like
crow i need you to grow up and mature
and let's go like i feel like we've
dragged on with him for season after
season so i was i was a little happy to
see progression there and some finale
him kind of conquer his demons so to
speak but honestly my fun
different cb like my fun is not i
recognize the season for what it is
right i i i could see where this is
gonna go and i'm not it may be the
tuesday situation but my fun has been
solar 3.0 i slept on it
i slept on it
it's nice it's nice yeah i came in
negative i think everybody was looking
for volatile rounds yeah it just felt
like everybody wanted solar volatiles
that's that's what it was and then when
people when it started hitting dude
they're just like it was like around
saturday yes so all of all of the reddit
all of twitter was just like look at
this build look at this build it's like
yeah that's your [ __ ] takes time exactly
i agree
the fusion star fought
protocol built that i got right now
with the with the other aspect where you
it does that extra pop on the grenade on
a fusion grenade yeah bro like walk like
at first i was like damn titans are
shining right now
hunters
what's going on i was feeling away like
i was looking at all the the stay alive
bills the resilience bills and i'm like
where's my low but i have the front like
the software protocol and what's those
boots those the booths are really good
oh they're they're really good yeah you
get a radiant all the time and you're
always reloading all your weapons
and now that you've got that icarus
change coming too so yeah let's see
but that's what so so my fun has been in
the build
bring us down to the earth on this
season because your face says it all
yeah y'all are a bunch of destiny simps
and somebody needs to put you in line um
so yeah i i said that the uh the
seasonal title for this uh the season of
the haunted is very apt name i said that
last week and i stand by it because
destiny itself is haunted it's haunted
by its engine that is uh is cracking and
breaking under the weight of its age uh
which we're now seeing and that it's
haunted by uh it's storytelling uh
issues and it's crope opera as i call it
uh with uh with you know dealing with
aldrin and all that for multiple seasons
i'm hoping that it'll be over um but
yeah that we'll see we'll see if they
continue on with that um and it's also
haunted by the fact that you know this
whole vaulting thing it seems like the
vault is sort of just being used as a
way to resell you the same content you
know they got the they got the leviathan
out of the vault they gave it a nice
little once over with some black paint
uh through some you know some spooky
some spooky moon vibes in there through
the phantoms from the old uh uh
what is it shadow
shadow keep came through that in there
and now uh they're just having you run
around so i don't know second week it
still feels very bare bones in in terms
of the amount of content that you're
given i agree with everyone that the
story is good i disagree about the
weapons not that they're bad i just
think that you've see i mean how many
new weapons are there there's they're
they're again
issuing a lot of the same weapons
yeah well there's 11 new there's like
then there's the opulent four that i can
have offhand at least a lot of a lot of
the same you know reissue weapons which
we've we've litigated a million times
and kind of the issues with that um and
uh yeah i'm i'm not feeling great about
the season so far i i thought the
dungeon was good i played the dungeon
and uh over the weekend thought it was
it was fine but um i just uh
it's
i i think there's a reason that we
didn't see a trailer for this game oh
it's coming full circle
i don't i don't think bungie agrees with
that at all i i mean i don't think
that's why
i agree with that that's why i'm right
i mean the way that was worded was like
they knew people weren't gonna like it i
think they knew they didn't need
marketing because people were going to
like it i think the aesthetic carried
the entire i agree
because yeah the trailer reaction people
freaked out yeah i i i agree
i think bungie and i like i i there's
obviously different approaches to the
game but
um you know i i do every time triumph i
get every seal and stuff and i have too
much [ __ ] to do like i cannot keep up
right now
it's not it's like grinding for all this
stuff yeah trying to get our chores
though
some people enjoy that right like that's
that's what half of destiny has been
since the truth triumphs were introduced
in forzakin
so
i mean content some people run content
once or twice and that's fine some
people check par check checkpoint farm
like garden of salvation that's fine but
it's like this this
the new evolving model for destiny is
very much like
hey
these are the activities here are
optional things to keep you playing the
activities but not everyone does it and
so i get why people don't like it but
you know i feel like
if you're approaching it like that
you're only ever going to like the major
expansions and that's it
right just the the huge drops of brand
new content that you can do a couple of
times well i mean i think we used to get
a little bit more from these sorts of
expansions maybe not in the seasonal
model but there have been good seasons
there have been seasons i like and i
just think that this one is definitely
one of the more lacking ones and yeah if
you live in the destiny bubble and this
is all you play and you go after every
season you'll have stuff to do my
question is is that stuff good
are you enjoying the stuff that you're
doing and i would just say like this the
grind that i have in front of me if i
want to get all those seals and stuff
it's not a pleasant one it's me doing
the exact same activity inside of the
leviathan a space i've already been to
basically doing the uh that opening
encounter you had to do to get to each
other when you're on the clock
yeah stella stuff it's it's you doing
that sort of thing and uh i don't know
if that's worth you know a purple name
over my head or uh the odd uh weapon
that i probably already have a pretty
decent uh version of you know something
like that and then the volume
yeah
i'm not saying there isn't plenty to do
they're keeping the treadmill well fed
for the people who want to run on it i'm
just asking is that is that treadmill a
fun experience and i would say unless
you're unless you're really really
willing to kind of close your eyes and
grit your teeth and go through it it's
not
you know it's not my favorite experience
they put into the game sure sure
one thing that's kind of related to that
that i'm really interested of is you
know them bringing back all of these
uh experiences i know we'll get to the
dungeon but for instance the tribute
hall is in the dungeon
and like how much work would it have
been for them to like just bring back
the tribute i i wish they would have it
it definitely was like everybody was
expecting once we saw trevi hall yeah
because bungie's made clear that like
the whole the reason that everything's
not just brought back is because when
they put stuff in the dcv it has to be
completely reworked to work with the new
engine updates so they've said that a
hundred times but like it has it's in
the game like the space is in the game
they've reworked those assets
so like what
what's the
there's a missing piece here that i'm
not seeing and i i don't know and it's
the same thing with like the leviathan
raids like all of those spaces have been
reworked they're in the game right now
we can go and access them so like
what's missing partially i'm gonna be
real and i don't know when it's going to
happen but there's at least from a
technical standpoint i know there's
there's limitations in the background of
keeping last gen alive
and i just don't i don't i don't know
what i don't know when we're going to be
able to walk past it because of the
scalping situation and in my opinion
they probably wouldn't need to say
something around now if lightfall was
going to leave ps4 in the old xbox but i
think i think we're about at the point
from at least a technical standpoint
where they were struggling to develop
king's full because they were developing
it trying to make it work with ps3 and
xbox 360 and and so i think there are
things in the background that we don't
quite understand fully so i try to give
them a pass on that but i really do hope
that we can
if it's not lightful then final shape
yeah move on to the to the next
generation of destiny because i i i
think at least the developer in me is
thinks that's what it is because if not
i'm with you scare i think it's an easy
win yeah to bring that in so that's
that's what i think at least okay yeah
now i'm with you i mean me and you've
been kind of
blaring that trumpet for the longest
as far as like yo it needs to happen but
again it's all about the analytics and
the user engagement that they're seeing
on those older platforms and i think
they need to be more comfortable
and then just think about teddy 2 the
adoption rate of these new consoles
right how many people really have
next-gen for them to kind of maybe
justify the full cut off so i think
those are the internal discussions again
like cb said that maybe we're not privy
to and that's why but i'm with you for
selfishly
i would like them to get a pig
you guys ever go and hang out with like
your casual friends that are you know i
play a few games like i uh i went to a
wedding this weekend and you know i'm a
i'm an extreme gamer they're like you
know they've got a and it was so weird
hearing that everyone's still on the ps4
and xbox one like everyone there they
were like
i got ps4 i'm thinking maybe i'll
upgrade ps5 maybe in 2023 i'm not really
sure stuff like that and it wasn't even
on their mind it was like everyone and i
would i was they were like how about you
travis and i was like i got them all man
i got oh led switch ps5 xbox series x
you know four series s's and they were
like what is wrong with you that's a
separate conversation but uh i love it i
love it
i i would be willing to bet that most
people playing destiny they're they're
probably they
they are you're right why do they need
to buy a ps5 when the only game they
play is on ps4 destiny
and that's what i think yep that's a
good point
yeah
well that kind of gets our feel of the
season so far nicely well-rounded i
would say everybody um
one thing i did want to ask you guys
each
um
favorite gun so far that you've got from
this season
storm chaser by far oh we got that stone
chaser yeah i have auto loading firing
um liquor coils in um charge
oh that's just
i've run it i've run it like 40
something times so i finally did get it
and um wow
it's it's it's ridiculous
nice every single one when you fire oh
my bad i was like every time with firing
line if you're um shooting all three
you're getting like 46 on like all three
of them jesus yes it's just busted so
it's a triple it's a difference
it's doing so it does like per burst
like three times as much damage as a
single shot of reads
and it shoots faster than a single shot
at first
and i have charge time on it i'm just
like sweating tears for that damn reads
with the [ __ ] you mean to tell me
yourself
it's been out my
and the intrinsic perk for duality is if
you get hit you reload faster and then
pretty much every boss fight now you're
getting hit so you get like free rapid
hit just like that
my
it's time to move on it's the
stormbreaker meta
jesus what is it is it arc is it what is
it arc it's arc uh yeah i think it oh i
don't really i thought he was a stasis
no i i'm a logan maybe i don't know i
don't know because
of stasis
it's already beaten the captain
what's the vowel one cataclysmic linear
what's it
yeah it's not even close like i said
people so you know i i missed the whole
launch of the dungeon and i people were
telling me about it last night and i was
like there's no way because everyone's
like oh this [ __ ] is just it's just
busted and so i was like looking
it's like stupidly good
which is pretty cool i'm definitely
gonna spend a lot of time farming for it
because it's uh it's a beauty for sure
[Music]
you pop in sparrow
uh i haven't gotten that one yet i'm
still still looking for it uh i've been
rocking new purpose the pulse rifle from
the uh the stasis pulse rifle yeah
um i got a roll with desperado and
perpetual motion so it's like
essentially the same as messenger but
it's
way cleaner it takes up less your screen
the sights of you know the duality thing
is just like uh it's like the two dots
it's oh it's beautiful scary i just got
it last night how's desperado feel now
that they've tweaked it it's definitely
slower it's slower okay it's it's a one
it's it's probably about half as fast as
it used to be um
it's still very good
uh especially you know if people were
running around i don't know if you guys
saw this but with um
radiance and
messenger with something like kill clip
you one burst and so with desperado you
like one and a half bur you know yeah
zero you're killing people like one and
a half or two bursts and it's it's so
fast
and so
um
this
the time to kill is getting kind of
absurd
with some of these converse there's
power creeps standing standing yeah
yeah
it was like when bungie said they wanted
70 of crucible to be guns i didn't
expect call of duty guns you know
the destiny guns it's uh it's it's very
uh
yeah it's it feels great though i
recommend yeah cb try it out because it
feels very good yeah i just got it to
drop last night so i'll try it yeah it's
a nice one
nice nice steady what
in your season so far old reliable
funnel web which is actually just for
clues
still rocking it
i had 200 000 kills on rekluse and i'm
approaching probably like 40k on funnel
web and
until something out classes that
leave it they're taking it off you're
taking it off okay and you like that
more than like uh the mini tool with
incandescent because that's probably my
second favorite right now
when you get that try it out because
they made me take funnel web both i i
haven't had time to i didn't play a lot
the first week yeah so i didn't i didn't
really get to like the grind and then
this week that was my goal but then iron
banner came around i played that for the
last two days so yeah um
i'll uh i'll get to this give that a
shot yeah
i know the right the red border farm
isn't isn't too great this time around
them so
oh wow it's getting lots of running in
circles
[Music]
yeah for me um
it's funny because i haven't got any
good rolls on a lot of the new stuff yet
so it's been a lot of also surprisingly
i've been like testing a lot of the the
buffed stuff
and machine guns is in a really good
place the 360s i have like a arc on
something with a um
auto roading and and
rampage and it just it it's hard like
i'm just like yo but she i feel the buff
of legendary machine guns on that
leviathan's breath is outside i'm
letting y'all know right now that thing
oh
breath is ridiculous like it's that it's
the second blast because you get the
first one
archer's tempo hits and right when
you're about to shoot your next shot you
get that poof damage after the so it
almost feels like lasting impression now
is on top of the initial shot levi's
brush is stupid
does that have intrinsic is it unstop on
it yes and that's what happens
i'll give it a try i'll give it a try
yeah bust dust off the leviathan's
breath that's been good um what you call
it um the the the air apparent not not
that bad or dps either i'm messing
around with that
and um the last one is even though i'm
not a sniper guy i finally got my first
incandescent roll with beloved and i'm
like yo this is nice that i i can't wait
to get with you the one you got you said
the um what is it the um tip mini tool i
don't know yeah yeah it's very good with
the condenser
yeah i haven't gotten it yet but yeah i
mean i've been kind of messing around
with the older stuff and then obviously
with the stuff we talked about with vex
is just stupid right now we're in
conjunction with the the warlock boots
and stuff like that but yeah it's mostly
also i've got good rolls i got the auto
i think it's a 450 precision i think i
got like a dodger on it i will say it's
very accurate for a 450. it does jump
around a lot so i thought that was cool
but yeah i'm still waiting for some some
better rolls but what about you trevity
any weapons any old favorites anything
you've been messing around with weapon
wise yeah i finally got a good roll
callus mini tool and that's been
hard to get rid of it's a great great
feels good
900's always hit or miss but man that
one just brought it back it's good it's
very much in the pvp meta right now so
that's been my go-to
wow
nice nice well also trespasser jesus
dude the trespass is unbelievable
yes
yes disgusting in pvp i haven't tried it
in pvp yet yeah yeah
okay that's a new uh stasis fusion rifle
from riptide crystal the thing is good
too that thing's good
i got a perpetual chill chill clip or
i'm sorry not petrol a compulsive chill
clip
and uh that is
that is beautiful
yeah yeah what about you
uh i've busted xenophage back out of the
vault and i've been having so much fun
it just feels good they finally got the
the rate of fire back up and then with
solar and then they've got the exotic
they're the mod where exotic solar
weapons can make wells and then it's
just it's a nice combination amongst
other things so no i've been having fun
with xenophage and then the inyo d it's
the a little smg it's like 600.
yeah that one feels i got like a feeding
frenzy rampage so i'm like i got like a
really good roll on it and it just kind
of feels very solid and reliable right
now is that a pvp or pve i think
i'm using that in pve right now just
like okay
i was calling it baby antiope oh
yeah
that's the name yeah
but yeah i got first drop of the season
i literally loaded into the castle in
the containment got a random drop and it
was a rampage feeding frenzy nyod and
it's just like i haven't used it yet but
it's like it's got range masterwork
extended mag extended barrel like
everything you would want on it i
haven't touched it but maybe i will
but uh
yeah i'll i'll check it out that's it i
totally forgot i had that so thank you
for bringing that up yeah nice there's
been a couple of nice surprises we got a
solar legendary bow i don't have a good
roll on it yet but that'll be coming
from vanguard so good to see that's back
in the mix as well
very nice um so yeah big thing we
launched after the last podcast dungeon
so we didn't know anything about it
going in and we now have
duality so it is here takes place as you
guys said kind of starts out in the
tribute hall
and it's
it's gonna it's an interesting one i've
heard kind of some people
having some like hey there we want enemy
density oh it's too much and then it's
just kind of a weird little back and
forth that we're kind of here and so i
wanted to get you guys takes on it for
those which i think everybody's played
at this point so i might be fresh i want
to let you go first yeah i might need to
go first because i'm literally
at the end so i'd rather you guys talk
afterwards because i'm really at the
boss but um
look you know
this thing great i mean dungeons always
interested me how they gonna approach it
and i was regarding the leviathan and
stuff like that so the first thing off
the bat the lore aspect i'm feeling it
they took the approach with the whole
shooting the bells
duality switch alternate reality switch
what i really like
i don't know how i feel about the
aesthetics of the like super red red red
like it's like very i don't know about
color saturation on my tv on my old end
stuff might be off because i'm like man
this is really fiery
yeah
like jesus i get it i'm in another
dimension thank you know what i said but
other than that like um not it's cool
e you hit out the paw the thing that
i've noticed that uh teddy's probably
laughing because he heard me like
screaming at i'm like yo i keep dying
i'm like yo where these enemies coming
from like it felt like battlegrounds in
a dungeon i'm like yo they are coming
out of the woodwork
no this is cool like i'm really fighting
for my life you don't know where it's
going so i think the last economy was
like like 15
70 right now it's 70 yeah yeah like 70.
i'm making sure i want you guys to go in
depth and please boy i do not care
because i got i pretty much know where
it's going i know who i'm fighting and
that is so cool because i i'm seeing
the vulnerability of kallus
on certain levels and the things he's
saying and how he feels about kaido and
and then gaul's place and i've always
felt this story was interesting the
aesthetic is cool i like the gong thing
you know with the last economy and kind
of stunning her and stuff like that but
so far so good i'll let you guys go in
depth but uh so far really if it ends
i want you guys to tell me if you're
satisfied after you beat it because i
feel like right now it's like this for
me like i'm loving it i'm really
enjoying it a lot and i want to know
where you guys that beat it your overall
hierarchy compared to other dungeons so
i'll give it to you guys i'll get to the
hierarchy so save that for
a bit
teddy what about you man
um i liked it
uh it has a very zelda-like mechanic
where it's sort of using uh the same
space but two different versions of it
and i've kind of always wanted some
version of that in destiny so i'm glad
they've
come to that realization and made
something
the loot is really good for the most
part as we we talked about obviously the
linear is like clearly busted um but all
the other guns i think everyone's been
talking about too have been
it's generally positive even the the
crown of sorrow the two guns that came
back
um i think uh the machine gun get
killing tally it can just
finally finally just got a killing tally
field prep one so
i did i did two two with you
nice i think
the fusion rifle feels out of place
though does it come with anything good
it just killing tally seems really great
on the fixed odds but it's like the
epicurean when we just got like three
other cracked fusion rifles like that's
a weird that's a weird choice uh i think
the armor set is definitely a miss i
know some people like it but
whatever i'm not gonna
no i'm would you fault them for that you
know it's fine um but overall i like the
mechanic i i like the
they've gotten a lot better since like
around
shadow keep of
introducing a mechanic whether it's for
raid or dungeon and then just building
off that whereas kind of before we
sometimes we're doing a lot of different
mechanics and then they all culminated
at the end so i'm much happier with this
like
single through line
through quick interruption it's carol is
it me did i miss without i liked what i
saw cuff in the dog and then i missed it
i remember the days when you had when it
wasn't like all right chicken heart um
whole through heart and yeah
one cool little tidbit about that um
is the the order of the of the call outs
for the first and second encounter are
the same as calluses throne world or
throne room from the original leviathan
they're in the same order but for some
reason on the final boss title they they
flip one of the sides it's not the same
so i don't know if that was a mistake or
like if it's just a weird coincidence or
what but yeah uh but yes i i do it's
nice having those symbols it's way
better than like
black mesa having a picnic on a colorado
plateau
yeah it was it was fun overall like we
did a blind and uh i will say though the
first time we went to the nightmare
realm uh my my reaction was am i playing
virtual boy right here like is that
what's happening uh that is the red the
red the red was really strong and i'm
like i like this is a little a little
too much but i like the aesthetic it's
nice so um overall it's got two thumbs
up for me the triumphs thankfully are
not like
super bad that's usually you know you
know me that's yeah if they do bad
triumphs i'm like oh eye roll here we go
like
so i do like that the um certain tribes
boost your exotic chance for the sword i
think that is like really perfect change
finally some way
at least when i get to 40 runs you know
i felt like i somehow made it better uh
instead of just
uh screaming at the heavens hoping that
it drops for me so but uh what about you
guys what do you what do you guys think
uh for me i mean i love it i mean
there's like a lot of things i think in
this dungeon to really love i mean i
don't think it's perfect but like um to
start off weapons i mean i already said
my favorite one storm chaser but in
general weapons i think we're a huge win
like huge huge win and to be honest i
think it's worth recognizing that
it's the first time in my opinion we've
ever gotten dungeon weapons because i
just don't consider i don't consider you
know is luna and matador and you know
like those are those were they're they
dropped in the dungeon but i i was i was
using them when i was in college in
2014.
you know like
they dropped out of the dungeon but
and then if you backtrack to then
prophecy you know you obviously get
things
and then even before then then you got a
moon weapons that were dropping just on
the moon if i did alters anyways and
then the shattered you know retail tail
i could get in blind well so absolutely
i think i think it was worth recognizing
that it was like the first time we we
really did get a a unique set of
weapons and armor now with that being
said i agree the armor definitely did
not i think live up to the expectations
we saw from the weapons i agree with
that like i think you're 100 right on
that teddy um
it's growing on me a little bit as i
find some different shaders but um but
overall they don't hold the candle to
the weapons like i think most people
will agree with that
um the lore i thought was fantastic um i
think giving um one of our like you know
biggest enemies like a touch of humanity
was really cool like i think a lot of
bosses sometimes you know we go into
garden salvation we kill giant robot
with no feelings no emotion no nothing
like that's kind of like the normal
trend we kill big thing that's just some
pure evil not really anything to it boss
there's some that are different savitun
i think was a big change to that and
some others have been too so i'm not
gonna say every boss but it is cool
seeing the humanity side to to callous
the regret yeah the the regretting not
being a great father seeing that how
much title really did mean i mean he
wanted her to rule the universe with him
at his side
my shining star right
and he said she was more beautiful than
any star he had seen like six saying
that and then even if you get all of the
dialogue
though
and then even like all the dialogue at
the end then it even builds up to final
shape stuff like as you yeah and as you
read and listen to some of the stuff at
the end it's like holy cow like kalos is
about to make this gigantic leap um
and like give up basically his like kind
of
i guess he's not humanly formed he's not
a human but what he currently is for
something greater and um and it and i
just think like the lore was nailed um
and that was really cool and to hear the
interaction of him talking the whole
time was was awesome
and then lastly just in terms of
mechanics and how the dungeon plays um
i i just think it's a very fluid
experience like it's buggy to a certain
degree i know people say it's buggy or
that there's a lot of enemies but
overall i mean i i feel like i blinked
and i did 50 runs
and i haven't been able to do that since
outbreak or whisper like i'm
legitimately just just running it and
it's just therapeutic
like i'm able to kind of almost even
just
i mean i don't i don't know it's just
there's some sort of therapeutic aspect
for me at least that i haven't felt in
in a decently long time and i've been
loving just you know running people
through and we're just hanging out and
talking and enjoying it
it's it's um experience for me i haven't
enjoyed as much since in my opinion
shattered
okay okay
that's that's just me
i agree with a lot of that i so just to
hit on the armor i mean are we all is
everyone in the world in agreeance that
like the season pass armor obviously was
supposed to be the dungeon armor
it's the same aesthetic as the weapons i
don't know why they flip-flopped on it
uh i wish they wouldn't know well we
know what yeah
but like yeah i don't know man
it's a shame even to be fair those
skirts to touch on that point if they
would have reversed it then it would at
least it would have been 20 for the
dungeon pass i guess
yeah
i don't know i don't know
it doesn't we have the armor anyways
it's whatever um
yeah the weapons the rewards from this
dungeon are insane they're they're
they're also good
uh the mechanics you like like everyone
said they're great uh
i really love the lore uh one thing i
think this dungeon does really well that
like shattered really missed on and
prophecy really missed on is it is
a continuous like it does so for
instance like prophecy you you're going
fast and fast faster you hit cube room
and it just slams to a halt and then
it's just like uh
awful same thing with the shield
encounter
um
same you know uh in uh in uh grasp of
avarice it's like you're going going
boom and it's just this dungeon doesn't
do that you're you're constantly going
fast i'd say my one complaint is with
everything with the leviathan for
whatever reason they love to have 20
20-minute long traversal sections oh
they love that yeah they just anytime
callous is involved they're like all
right the longest jump puzzle we've ever
done
but there are cool little
tricks to get around it so like in the
first jump puzzle where you're hitting
the bells and you're switching there's a
couple parts where like you start up
high and really you know the the
intention is you hit like a bell and you
zigzag down the floors but you can just
jump all the way down to the bottom one
and skip two or three and so there's
there's a couple sp like spots where you
can do just stuff like that
um the encounters are so fluid i so keep
in mind i didn't start i didn't get back
to last night i didn't do the dungeon
until last night and my friend i i went
in solo and blind
and i sold it all the way up till uh the
final boss and i got like two or three
damage phases in
way under leveled because i i played one
day last week before we left so i i'm at
like 63 or something like way under
level for the final boss and i was like
this is gonna take too long so then we
i've now completed it like four times
with the full fire team once on master
um
it's
it flows so well like it's it is
all of the mechanics flow very well into
each other it's all very cyclical going
between the realms and i think it all
feels fantastic i love the enemy density
personally
uh i i think i'm a fan of it i i'm a big
like
forbearance guy and that just you know
bigger explosions the more enemies in a
room there are so there you go oh chain
reaction and then you know i've been
using the solar titan builds and stuff
where that forbearance is sick too
it's not coming off i'm telling you
right now it's a bunch of nerves yeah
that is
it is in that slot permanently
so uh
yeah i i don't know man i
i love this dungeon everything about it
the aesthetic the
all the mechanics feel very good every
time bungie comes out with a piece of
end game content i'm always like this is
it this is like there's no they've done
everything there's no way they can come
up with another unique mechanic and then
they do it every time and it always
blows my mind it's like i never would
have thought about this
so i always think that's kind of cool
um yeah uh
i i also like the dungeon uh i i think
to everyone's point the loot has been
quite good the armor is
super annoying we do know why that was
taken out uh but you know business is
business
um
they can't give you armor that that's
cool for free come on at this point
that's sort of destiny's brand like if
the if it's look super sick you're like
oh man i can't wait to pay ten dollars
for that and if it looks uh it looks
kind of rubbish you're like can't wait
to grind 40 hours for that
so yeah that's not new uh but the
weapons are cool i like that they put an
exotic in a dungeon that's gonna give me
more because i'm not somebody who's
really done dungeons a bunch of times
but since this one has
a grindable exotic i like that it's a
farmable dungeon huge huge w you can
just play it over and over again it's
really cool
sorry to that point um
i have heard that the sword is not
farmable scary that i've heard from
other people i don't think i don't think
it is i'm 50 and it hasn't dropped okay
i am all right okay yeah it's i don't
think it is like i did it back and forth
too but it would have dropped me by now
i even have like the collections and
stuff but everything else is farmable
right
everything else is world cv if that
changes i i'll be the first
i'll dm you first
i'll let you know
okay um so yeah i think that's cool i'll
probably just do it once a week then in
hopes of getting that sword um but yeah
i also do want that fusion rifle or
yeah linear fusion yeah yeah where does
it drop
your counter
anyone else
the linear drops the second to last and
the last you can get it from the yeah
because i've got i i've got it from the
like the
the right before the kaido encounter
okay that's that's the majority of time
where i get it okay i just put the root
table in chat oh i think it's perfect
in this uh call yep i see yeah so that's
cool uh and um yeah the core mechanic is
also pretty interesting
um
the environments again we're in the
leviathan not my favorite thing uh and
also the
nightmare realm in addition to this the
color scheme i'm sort of disappointed
that there's not really like anything
different about the world except for
that it's red and you can only be there
a limited time i mean it has different
you know there's no
not different types of enemies there or
some like special objective you have to
complete or anything like that it's sort
of just like
you know again we're using the same
space which you know it's a clever way
of doing that if you if you have limited
uh space that you can put in the game
and that it's just an off-season but um
yeah if i had to nitpick those are the
things i think they could have done
better but yeah on the on the whole i
think it's a really solid piece of
content probably one of the better
dungeons they've done
um
yeah i want to do it solo i actually
want to try it this year yeah we'll see
higher level i'm not going to be able i
can't do like scaro 1263 and solo it i
can't do that
i mean i could but it would it would it
would take me dozens of hours and i
ain't got that kind of time man i gotta
i got it i gotta review some two out of
ten games
to the aesthetic point i don't know if
anyone noticed this i'm sure some people
have it maybe hasn't clicked or whatever
but as you get further in the raid the
leviathan is turning more into a pyramid
ship
like there's more
you get you get like a ball case in
amber tort before the final encounter
and then you get like the
the witness statue things and all over
the place right before and so it makes
me wonder is part of the season
narrative
is maybe kalos isn't claiming the
pyramid ship on the moon maybe the
leviathan is turning into a pyramid ship
because the if in the severance mission
this week they talk about how the
leviathan is constantly mutating and the
weapons
look like like the seasonal weapons yeah
they look like leviathan weapons that
are being turned into
like val the disciple weapons they've
got the same sort of architecture
starting to form so what if
the leviathan turns into just a pyramid
ship that'd be dope you know or like a
pyramid-ish ship it's gonna be one of
the bigger ones than i'm sure because
then yeah it's huge
it'd be i i think that would be a cool
little twist on it it'd be very callous
as well you know
i don't need that ship i've got my own
yeah
that'd be i think it would be cool so
that's really cool
yeah all right real quick everybody's
gonna go around i want in order i want
your number two dungeon
and then your number one dungeon oh [ __ ]
damn it's hard now
what's up
i'm gonna go the way my screen shows for
me so i'm going cb you're first i need
your number two dungeon
this one then shudder there you go
that was a number two number one so
shatter always my number one for what it
did to the game
for what that did to the dreaming city
for
what it did to the curse on the curse
for what it did for the dreaming city as
a space for the last wish unlocking it
for all the lord that came with it for
the ascendant challenge and everything
all coming together and making the
dreaming city what it was there's never
been an experience since um and i really
hope that they changed the sabbath
throne world to start being more
interactive with stuff because let's be
honest it's been three months and what
are we doing in the throne world right
now like shattered shattered throned it
more for the game than a lot of people
realize so
that's that's where i'm at and then this
one is number two for me okay
oh it's it's such a hard one um
yeah i i am also
anyone who knows me knows i am like the
biggest symptom for recency bias on the
planet every time a raid comes out i'm
like this is my favorite like no matter
what every time except one volatile
glass 2.0 came out but oh good that's
hard to have recently bias for that
guy
oh man i might i might have to go with
cb on this one actually uh i really like
shadow thrones easier it's less dungeony
it's less intense but it's very
like any time i'm warming up for
anything or i'll just go like solo the
shattered throat like it's a great
it's just a great time i always enjoy it
it's a great fall guys are out good
that's all i'm not gonna waste your time
enjoy let me know which one's your
favorite show you guys love the
engagement i just started playing
yesterday like i don't know i in terms
of aesthetics it already puts it near
the top and it doesn't have any of those
super like so like grasp of avarice i
immediately knew that wasn't going to be
one of my favorites because of the
shield encounter like the one encounter
i was like this is this is
yeah i didn't like it uh same thing with
prophecy pitifully's fine but it's a lot
of running uh but shattered thrown is
always sweet short to the point and this
one i feel like it flows very well so
yeah probably number two for me as well
[Music]
ready
it's just good you know there's nothing
no i mean it's a classic it's
um i might have to agree uh shadow
throne for all the reasons that cb
outlined um i think that's the best one
but i will define my second one i'll say
prophecy only because only i do agree
that the the second encounter or the
cuban counter as well as the the
encounter and grasp for the children are
just kind of ruins the whole flow but
it's the closest thing we've ever gotten
to sparrow racing
but yeah
i like this one too i i think i i
haven't played it that much i did grind
the boss a little bit last week but i
haven't got enough time in yet to like
really say definitively whether i like
it but i do agree the flow of this one
feels really good it feels like shadow
thrown where you're just kind of it
feels like you're constantly moving but
it's not like a pit where you're just
running sort of needlessly and yeah
backtracking a bunch here's another
tunnel
that's the that's the tagline for a pit
of heresy
damn another tunnel travis
i'm also going to go shattered throne on
this one um wow unanimous as number one
and uh prophecy is number two so i guess
i'm same as teddy uh my reason for
shattered throne is
the thing i remember most about that one
is
you know in addition to the
discoverability and being like yo
uh i didn't know that this was here but
i remember as soon as i was finished
with it we went back in because somebody
on twitter read reddit or something had
discovered the secrets and the bow was
starting to get discovered so we went
back into it and we started like
searching for that that quest line and
trying to figure out how to get that bow
and
i just remember that being so damn cool
on top of an expansion that was already
so good and had so much stuff i wasn't
expecting so that's huge and then for
prophecy i just think uh when it comes
to dungeon mechanics i don't think that
they've done better than the shadow and
light thing because that was such a cool
damn mechanic uh and i think that's
probably the best
dungeon specific like raid mechanic that
they've ever put in the game uh and it
was just so cool like figuring it out
and being like oh it's when i'm in
shadow or in light that's what's causing
the difference here and then and then uh
applying that to all the fights was just
really cool so
i also really like just uh i like any
boss fight where you're chasing somebody
in a hallway
that's a thing in dark souls as well
they'll put like a boss at the end of
the hallway and you have to like survive
all of its fights as you all that's
blast as you run toward it and so
anytime they do that i'm sort of a
sucker for that fight you're like
running down a hall
nice guy he didn't just stand there and
have a shoot at him yeah yeah
yeah chad stovade um
i don't wanna i wanna be a prisoner at
the moment because i love diwali but
it's too early i need to
process a little more you know saying
before but i think it's gonna fall
in that three two or three
range you know say but
prophecy is my baby prophecy is my baby
i love prophecy it's the same thing he
said i think it has a nice balance of
different mechanics like um travis said
the lightning dark the boss fight really
is fun because what i like about the
chasing also if you get caught and
penalized you get sent back and i
thought that was an interesting mechanic
during a boss phase i like the aesthetic
of the the encounters before with the
room changing the the the structure as
your
the cube room i thought that was cool
even the vastness of the outside
it's funny because the way y'all talking
about shadow i should have it up there
and i love it like i don't hate shatter
i i guess
i don't know i just got a weird thing
with it i was just like okay i did it i
loved it at the moment i know what it is
shattered i don't necessarily
care for replaying all the time whereas
someone asked me to do prophecy i'm in
there let's go you don't say that kind
of thing but shattered is amazing i
don't want to be i want to be i don't
want to be disrespectful because cb says
some great points the fact that the the
curse lifted and then this thing opened
up and then
you've always talked about seeing
where you have to go that's one of the
biggest things yeah as you can see
from the beginning yeah i love that i'm
going to start
the pot here you can pit as well though
you can see the flower
[Music]
i'm going to stir the pot and say cog it
sounds like you feel the same way about
shattered throne ascaro feels about
vaulted glass which is
even though it's the original it's the
progenitor to you it's sort of like
the the
prototype for what ended up becoming
more nuanced mechanics more
replayability whereas whereas uh
you know because that's the one thing
shadow throne doesn't have for it is it
doesn't really have any like
mechanical theme around it it's sort of
just you know you're fighting and you
work to the end and that sort of thing
so it is it's sort of like the way
dungeon and that is what a lot of that's
the biggest criticism of all the glass
is that it's sort of the prototype for
all raids to come after and either you
were there when it was originally came
out you have a lot of nostalgia and it's
your number one right or you think it's
the worst rate in the world and it all
just depends on your perspective so i i
see you guys you guys have something the
same that's a good point
there's a validity to some of it i i
don't i mean
i do think i need
a little bit more counters and that's
why duality is moving
up for me a little bit i i like that
gong mechanic i like the stun and then
when she runs at you whatever but i i
need to play it more before before that
that i think is another big one too that
i don't think we touched on enough to
that um
i would say with all of the bosses
besides
maybe i mean oh just in general like
most of them just aren't very mobile yes
now prophecies i'll give we did you know
teleporting yeah but like it was more
just teleporting than stand still but
kaido is very much very active just like
in following that up from rock same
thing with goron though exactly yeah
like very very active bosses i think
that deserves a little bit of credit too
i mean one thing i will say i'm in love
when shattered but i i i don't love it
so much that i'm blinded by it but duel
and cargo just stood there
and and you know after you slammed your
knights and got your three balls you
went and you blew her up the smithereens
and he's a passive okay that's what
that's what it is i think yeah shattered
throne i more appreciate the aesthetic
of it as opposed to the actual
encounters i don't feel like the actual
encounters out but what's that one where
you you guys you run around you kill the
witches and when
it's cool but it's like i think that's
my only thing i think i think i i
appreciate it more for for the aesthetic
and what it's doing for for the game and
then and then this is where i'm gonna
get on scarole now because he's being
very disrespectful i i'm also not a fan
of running dungeons and raids and i'm
not i don't feel the loot is where it
needs to be and i'm sorry wish
ain't my reason to keep coming back
that's fair i had this conversation with
rick uh cactus a couple years ago and he
he really harps on the loot and stuff
too and i think that mia
i think this comes down to how many
times you end up doing a dungeon or
raids you know i end up having a hundred
completions of every dungeon every raid
you know and it's like loot matters for
your first
five
six you know it's like after a while i
have everything i don't get excited when
something comes out of the chest
i get excited if the mechanics make me
feel good or if it feels like i'm doing
something or if it looks cool or
whatever and so um yeah i kind of get
that but to a certain point i've never
really minded that dungeons haven't had
great loot because they've always
offered like just a completely unique
experience that you couldn't get into
for sure
that's why like i love eater i love
spire of stars their loot was ass it was
so bad except for except for our toasty
mode of course yeah
but between them they had two armor well
like six armor sets and four weapons and
they all sucked they were all so bad but
i still love those rates
it's very much about especially yeah
like cb man yeah
this is this guy ran whisper 1400 times
or some [ __ ] you know
you're touching on exactly why i like
this dungeon and exactly why i love
shattered because you're right i mean
yeah between outbreak and whispers i'm
over a thousand times or whatever and
then with shattered i've done it
hundreds of times too and i feel like
that's where i'm going with this one
because it's you're right after three or
four times let's just be real we have
everything so it really does eventually
just come down to is this thing fun fun
yeah and that's why i love this one and
i think it's why i like shattered
because yeah you just kind of just start
and go and next you know you blink and
you're done and i'm just and you're yeah
you know it's it's just cool it's
beautiful there's no abrupt starts or
something yeah
heresy as number one
yeah
there you go no it's like hearing you
guys talk it's very hard to pick
it is really really difficult because
shattered throne i am with you guys the
fact that shattered throne is special it
was the first dungeon in the game first
thing i worked on soloing first thing
like not soloing not the first thing but
first like dungeon that we got to solo
and it was post whisper so it was like
whispers kind of lead into like this big
dungeon and then as you said cb is like
the effect of what it did to
it had story to it
which is one that i actually really do
like about this one that we've got of
like callus talking and kind of
understand what's going on a little bit
of the witness maybe a little
foreshadowing
all of that kind of ties in to be cool
it's shadowthrone is special because it
is one of those when i i played it i
liked it a lot and then we went to gcx
and i saw when they did the panel and it
was uh night hydra's the developer and
the shop
um
he was like one of the artists in there
it's like i know he was a big or she was
a big part of that
and
it was that revelation which i never had
because at the start like you can see
where you're going all the way in and
then you start looking through the whole
thing you're like oh i was i was down
there i was like over there there's all
these different places and you can go
through it's like some people may not
like the aesthetic of just like the you
know grayscale most of the time which i
know some people may not like that look
of it but on the other side it was
so it was just something we had never
experienced and i love that it was like
it was built for a solo so it is doable
but it's just that challenge and i love
that about all the dungeons period so
it's like shattered throne i'm sitting
here trying to like talk through it
this one is very good i'm enjoying this
one quite a bit i love the mechanics the
switch where you can when you get
efficient um salted grepo i think did
the run in like 22 minutes so if you
guys want to it's solo yeah
oh sheesh
yeah
yeah he went crazy my man's hitting
skips holy oh yeah and then
spopping them they're like almost on sub
10 runs like full fire team so yeah
there's some nice speeds going on oh my
god that's insane
oh yeah it's like you're gonna get to
where you can do it pretty fast so it's
like then again if you get to where you
can
speed run it is that something some
people enjoy that they haven't been able
to do before but i think if i have to
probably pick right now just because if
i take recency bias and know that that's
kind of in there i might go prophecy
shatter throne
that's big for you
that's big
i know you love shattered throne i was
like prophecy for me is probably one of
the hardest times i have fought with a
boss for whatever reason i just
struggled with it just the boss fight
the encounter because the triangular
room for whatever reason you start and
stuff is literally coming from every
direction it's not like you have a good
piece of cover in there there's like
little pieces of cover here and there
but it's like you kind of have to move
you have to kill things quick to try and
clear out one side and then you can kind
of have a little field then you start it
over depending on how many damage phases
you do if you're doing it solo it's like
three or four depending on what weapons
you're using and stuff like that and
also it was like the initial like this
is a boss that moves this is a boss you
have to chase this is a difference there
and as you said you had the rainbow road
so that was pretty special in there
because
i'm like
yeah so that was and then again the
aesthetic too like the cube room did
something in a space that i didn't think
that they would honestly really be able
to do
and that's why i was like i'm really
torn between duality and shattered
throne being like two but one two and
three are close
and then
that's the thing about grasp of everest
i know we got it with the 30th
anniversary and it was cool
but like when i go back to think about
playing it now it's
it's almost it might be my last one it
might be
aged really really yeah like heresy i
want to go back and play now to see how
it is but it's like i've done pit of
harassing enough like it has its moments
but it's like something about grass
especially like you know the shield
piece as well but i was like even the
ogre
piece now it's like you know the
mechanics but if you're a solo player
and you don't have like huge burst dps
you're gonna be doing like six damage
faces or something but it's like it's
that little sequence over and over so
i don't know i think prophecy for me has
like a special place for the look but
shattered throne is a damn close second
because it was the first that's right
there so i think that's where i gotta
put those two duality is like a tight
third the other two they're kind of
falling down the list i think right now
yeah and with grasp too like a lot of it
the novelty was like fan service which
wears off and then the whole first part
of the raid first quarter
is like traps and stuff which is funny
when you can trick your friends for the
first couple of runs
but then every subsequent run it's like
how quickly can i just like get through
this
it's just and i think it goes back to
that fluid it is scary too because if
for me at least i think the fluidity
gets cut off when you get to the server
part where you have to start um blowing
up the all the servers it just feels it
feels so slow and that and that's the
thing that kills me it kills that
fluidness like i feel like i'm at a halt
and i can't speed it up
each of the encounters requiring a
different number of exotic engrams for
each of their things uh their mechanics
is i don't like that either because it
it really
it just
it just feels it doesn't feel consistent
yeah i got you
it's yeah inconsistent that's a great
word for it so yeah i don't really like
that i think everything
in this new one duality
was is really good uh in terms of
keeping things consistent i my biggest
gripe and i don't know if this was just
me when i was trying to figure it out
solo the first encounter
where you were supposed to stand in the
rooms that you open and shoot the bell
my only gripe is i don't think that was
telegraphed at all
great point yeah yeah i don't know how
anyone like fig figured that out because
there's no visual indicator there's no
audio indicator you don't have a buff
nothing's showing on radar that gate far
away
and so it's like i i get like now that i
know what happens like oh of course
you're teleporting into a close room
you're killing it it's like it makes
sense there
but i think for a first run it wasn't
telegraphed well but now that i'm doing
it every time i do i'm like damn this is
cool and it feels good you're running
out of the rooms as quickly as possible
you're like your matrix style like
necking people
like get as much time for the boss as
possible i love that stuff dude it feels
so good so are we all in consensus that
grasp of average may have fallen
to the worst
it's definitely between that and pit for
me i think so yeah
for me i'm in the same bottom two though
with scarole yeah it's
pit's cool but a lot of the things again
with pit like the sword having to kill
the wizard with the sword always takes
forever like way too long
the streaker is the only one of the
three that's like fast to kill the other
two are kind of grueling and you have to
wait to get your health back and all
that and
they're fine the aesthetic's really cool
but it's a lot pit also has an
in-between encounter that takes forever
between the boss and the
the totems and it's just like it doesn't
need to be there i don't like it i don't
know i just feel like it's too long it's
too
long
yeah i don't know
[Music]
thing that i was thinking about too that
didn't make me like it a lot back in the
day too was that every three weeks
coming it gave it like a novelty too or
it's like an excitement when it was
first week to form it kind of almost
like how whisper would just be friday
like it was almost like an event yeah i
don't know when i used to like i'm glad
they've gotten away from that because
that limited time me too
back and then the moment you're like
oh i really want to run it but i can't
yeah he was like waiting too yeah
it wouldn't hold up now but back then it
was cool no
well honorable mention oh uh
crota's end
hey you're not you're not doing that
come on
i also i also think that the raid layers
are just dungeons to be honest with you
yeah get them try doing spider starts
with three people and tell me how that
works
especially
that would be yeah double primary that's
a no
back in the day at least when it was
telling me nobody's done spyro stars
three man you need five people to do it
yeah it's it's not possible you have to
have four people standing on plates for
the final two encounters not if not if
the three people all have telesto
equipped oh there you go yeah that's
fair that breaks up right
there you go um where's my opinion
giving banshee to lesto broke the tower
that's my favorite thing they can't even
put it in as an animation without
breaking something
so good it's officially very broken
yes nice man no i i i really i'm adamant
against the whole bringing crota's back
as a dungeon thing because it's like hey
this didn't meet our standards so please
make it objectively worse they were like
no it's like i want to see what the [ __ ]
looks like
i agree with skero because that's the
thing it that's what florida glass felt
like for me
with now because it seemed like they did
they tried to nail everything that they
weren't able to nail the first time in
d1 like because one of the first things
was okay you can shoot the oracles up at
the top with icebreaker and who cares
what the order is this time you don't
shoot in the right order you're done you
can't do that you gotta should write
order then you get to the templar it's
like what do we used to do in templar
ignore the oracles and just cleanse with
the shield you can't you can't ignore
the work well you you can't cleanse with
your shield you gotta and then you know
you get to the end and it's like and you
have to shoot the work like it just felt
like they they tried to do whatever they
failed yeah the first time so i want to
destiny too if i yeah i want to know
what they can do in terms of destiny
just make you not do be a hunter and
jump across the whole thing and that's
exactly right
exactly exactly
i i bet all six people would have to be
out there with swords whacking his ass i
bet he'd have just the stupidest shield
or something you know like i i don't
know for sure but i'm excited it makes
me excited that's why anytime someone's
like oh just make crota a dungeon i get
no stuff
they've done worse than that which is
that they've put crota back in the game
about 400 times yeah
just for the record i am trolling but
uh not joking they have actually like
put the crota's throne room in the game
as part of the shadow keep campaign
right one of the nightmares yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're right yeah it's kind of
already there in a way
i don't know i mean it could be the
community
how do you like that scarab it's not
even a dungeon
it's a mission
i like it better because i had to pay
for it again so that makes it that makes
me enjoy it more well low-key they
brought the gauntlet back
so like
it already the leviathan raids are in
the game
it's in the game it's in the game so
like
sports it's in the game please i'll buy
anyone a beer oh i'll give you a hug
i'll write you a nice letter like i just
just give it back you know it's like i'm
with you i'm with you yeah i mean
if it's basically there especially if we
go explore and we're like okay then
because we ran through with sayad we
were or i'm probably getting that name
wrong it's zavala's wife whatever i feel
like we ran through like the purple
covered floor so we had like the throne
room
like it's that was all at the beginning
and then we're gonna go back into
everything
yeah and then i know there's a picture
of like
the is it the aqueducts with like those
little like pipes that you walk on and
stuff because i remember some pictures
on the trailer there's like that wall
and like the great and the trees
underground it's like all these things
like the callus robots yeah exactly so
yeah the only parts i think we haven't
seen are the outside in the engine room
which was like the very center of the
underbelly with the fans advanced the
fans yeah yeah um
but like we have the rest is there you
know and i'm sure someone's ubed out of
bounds and they've seen and the the rest
is there too i i would bet
i just man
i just want to know i like i i hate
hardman on it for so much but i just
want like a
a dev update where it's like a
a written thing of like look we brought
these assets back this is why we can't
bring the rest of the assets it would be
nice if we could read those i'd be
really interested in like knowing the
limitations
there's a couple harp on it no no
there's a couple tech updates that i
would love to get
some questions on as well for sure yeah
it's because they they had to choose
between doing that or uh keeping
eververse while stalked
i mean obviously wins
yeah dude
yeah that's good still no glitches cog
by the way cog and i have a run a game
where we we count how many seasons there
are
uh many bugs in destiny but zero bugs in
eververse and yeah
it's looking pretty good she's efficient
man i mean
[Music]
what is what is uh the example of an
eververse bug i can't think of a single
one well there aren't any that's our
point
there's lots of bugs in destiny but zero
problems with eververse like i was
talking about like how they they capped
a currency when the community asked
about it they were like oh well there's
data problems and i was like really
because i've never had a silver cap you
know i've never worried about that
problem where i couldn't carry enough
silver
the only thing that was ever a glitch or
whatever was what the throttling or
something
i remember back in the day i was back in
the church
that's the only thing that's the only
thing that's the only thing i could
think of
i forgot about that
i think that's the only thing you could
put on the list maybe but was that was
that a glitch i can't remember how that
went down i don't i don't know
how did that go in a couple oh
it was somebody
will give you the history
will bring it out
i can't remember about you remember
somebody somebody counted pixels on
their screen like they've got some
speedrunning community people who do
that stuff and they counted pixels on
screen to see what was happening with
the xp because the numbers weren't like
adding up correctly that's how they
figured it out and then when they got
caught red-handed they were like
yeah we have this mechanic that
throttles you
and they they fix it i think with chris
osiris or maybe maybe right before that
but that was like kind of not a great
time for destiny because the
phase sort of had ended and that was
before christmas
uh as far as glitches forever there have
been a couple over the years where
uh either like bright dust uh something
happens where it doesn't refund you
correctly or it costs too much or like
the silver won't get offended and i will
say they fixed those things
the only other one was
and they fixed those really fast
like all right uh guys that needs done
in five minutes uh
they've been like a def con style
pentagon team that's just in a basement
somewhere and as soon as something bad
happens the lights start blaring and
it's like
weird think about like how many infinite
legendary shard glitches we've had and
infinite
cores and all this [ __ ] there's never
once been an infinite bright dust glitch
that stuff's coming from i think i think
the game would get turned on
there was a heavy ammo bug for like two
years there was that sprinting invisible
sprint cooldown bug for like two years
like all these huge crazy bugs and then
the ever and there was even that time
where all the menus were super slow
remember that yeah
unfortunately now that's still
unfortunate
you would just see you would see these
menus go by super slow with all these
frame rate issues and then you tab over
to every verse and it'd be like
immediately
ever ever verse reserves a very specific
spot in the front of your ram so it's
always the quickest access possible
everything else in the game sits on your
hard drive but eververse has the first
little block of
i've told this story before but in d1
they they when they increased their
vault space in rise of iron which was a
big like technological achievement they
made this huge post about how they saved
one megabyte of ram to get us this extra
volt space
but for three years in d2 they couldn't
give us more vault space until very
recently but they added eververse
everywhere so i'm sitting here you know
technical brain kind of being like you
guys freed up enough ram for eververse
to go everywhere everybody she's in
space you couldn't yeah you couldn't
free up just a little bit for that extra
vault space i needed i mean we got it so
i should have complained but
uh anyway i don't want to bag them too
hard i get it it's a business yeah we
can't bag on destiny guys we we all love
kenji bungie if you're watching and i
know you're watching i haven't gotten my
check yet if you're listening yeah he
hasn't gotten paid yet so he's really
grouchy today
but look bunji this isn't just our hobby
it's our destiny we're done with you
i'm done with you okay and on that
bombshell no just kidding um
all my friends for the time
two quick ones real quick i've missed a
couple of super chats
um five dollars holy smokes he said he
didn't know that many chairs yeah the
campfire is very full tonight but we are
having an absolute blast so thank you
guys for being here yeah and also gdo
he's just woke up here in the middle of
the night want to drop in quickly he's
over in like the netherlands if i
remember correctly
uh thank you for all that you guys do
for the community uh keep it up and i'll
catch the rest later so big fans for
everybody here on the show
that being said there's one more thing
that launched on tuesday and it's been
spicy yeah oh yeah so iron banner rift
is back we have three maps that it plays
on
convergence banner fall and then the new
one
what's the new one called this
dysfunction despacito this is
and convergence i have not seen the map
yeah i've seen the map one match
which you would think by the way
just for the statistical number of times
that i played iron banner
the new map might have a little bit more
weight than what i'm getting right how
have you guys seen it more have you guys
seen it a lot actually yeah
i've seen it i've talked about it quite
a few times two times
two times this season that's it wait
really that's it god i've i've gotten
dozens of times two times this season
i've played on the mountain
wow yeah i think people get bad luck
there should be voting but
here's the thing yes i agree here's the
thing about that map is it's very
clearly made for rift and it's obviously
of the three the best map it's like not
even close so when you play on the other
ones you're just like oh god yeah
especially bannerfall if you does not
feel like if you get wiped they're
dunking before you can res so i gotta
say right now bannerfall the original
rift map back in destiny it was yes it
was convergence
did they make it for that though i
thought it was in the game before yeah i
think it came out with ribs i think you
might be right
with that
rockstar
[ __ ] i think or whatever and i i
think it was bannerfall and rift
launched like two weeks before taking
king
i think if i'm right this was like eight
years ago one week one week yeah and i i
think that was the amount because the
microchasm was usable that that single
yeah that single week was the only time
necrochasm was actually usable uh during
a destiny one's lifespan but item
information
that just goes to show you how much
slower we were in destiny one because oh
yeah you could you could not dunk that
quickly and in in this one it's like
it's over if they wipe your team you fly
across the map yeah
i wanted to ask you guys
the one thing i've seen pretty
consistently where are your thoughts on
the respawn time because personally i
feel it's too long
it's that's a hard one right but i just
played the new map so again that i don't
know
i think you have to do a delicate
balance because if you decrease the
respawn time you obviously have to widen
the spawn area
right and so because you can't have just
people just spawning endlessly on where
you're supposed to dunk you would never
be able to dunk ever for sure um
and so i think it was the choice bungee
had to make was either hey you can spawn
halfway across the map
or you can
there's a six second respawn timer right
i don't know i've only played probably a
dozen i did both though there's a six
second respawn timer and you spawn
halfway across the map oh i haven't i
haven't personally noticed spawning
halfway across the map if that's a thing
then i don't know
oh yeah
dunking you'll spawn so far away and
it's like all right well then it's over
because well then yes if i didn't
realize that was a thing then respawn
should definitely be shorter it's such a
it's a hard balance they they did this
thing with this one where they made it
much more like a sports game where it's
like you score and then you reset do you
like that reset yeah we gotta talk about
this
to be honest i it feels does it feel
stagnant to you guys bro
i missed the old roof that's just me
i'm with you that's my issue like
that respawn just feels so disconnected
it just abrupt it pulls me out and look
i get i get it mechanically because they
don't want you after the dunk and the
play resumes right after that
yeah yeah but it just like
is it me and i don't disrespect budgie
if you're listening but it feels like i
get nervous when they pull me out and
then they get a black screen and then it
loads and i'm like i mean the tower this
season has led me to fear that a little
bit but yeah
bro it's crash the first time yeah i
felt like yo is it going to crash like i
was like
and those games are long sometimes bro
so i'm like yo they're way too long way
too low i'm like please don't crash and
if they don't hit if yeah if you don't
get they're either 30 seconds or
30 minutes you know what i mean like
that's consistency
yeah
if somebody doesn't if somebody scores
really fast like i've had matches end
like that we just dumped it five times
and then other times it's like
the full 10 minutes and you're sitting
there like dude this is not working yeah
this is not worth it yeah yeah
so
the reset thing's interesting because
it's like you know it's like are we
playing hockey or basketball you know
like what are we trying to be doing here
and i don't know i i get what they were
going for
but i also get like what why people
don't like it because it is very
stag it's stagnating or it's it's just
soft so yeah hold on let me get forte
real quick listen i don't hate it from
what it's trying to accomplish i just
don't like the way it's implemented it
just feels would you see like a stream
pop up with like two to two to one and
then like fade away like that like
you want to see a different screen not
so much like the reset you hate
it feels like they sending me to orbit
yeah
like it's just it's so abrupt i
understand it i don't have a problem
with resetting from a balance standpoint
but forte my only issue is just that
that part then you couple with the fact
that when it happened this was my first
experience playing riff it happened like
in the middle of the match on bannerfall
and then the spark didn't spawn and we
literally for five minutes just it was
team death match and no spark and i'm
like see
i knew this thing was gonna break the
game yeah
no i don't again i don't have any
evidence that that's the reason but it's
just it just feels mechanically
spaghetti code-ish like yo is something
wrong are y'all going off all of us are
going to get back to the same spot
please that's what it felt like so
that's all it was to get off yeah yeah i
also i
i was i didn't really have an opinion at
first on
uh the rift holder being able to shoot
but after seeing it in action i kind of
hate it they know they have to stop it
because eager's edge it has to be stuff
yeah yeah i agree with you shoulder
charge oh i didn't even think about it
you can eager's edge across the map and
slam oh my god it's super bad people are
doing that yeah i've seen that also um
like the teamwork of like people having
to guard you was a thing in the original
rift or you try to just make a break for
it by yourself and i think you were i
think you were a little slower
yeah yeah and um like this one like
there were there was clearly a route
happening like the the team that had the
ball were all rushing toward us and our
team want to fight them and i was like i
bet you the rift holder's not there so i
went to the side and i found him he was
going around a secret pass i was about
to cut him off and then this dude just
shoots a galler horn at me
like what am i supposed to do he just
had power yeah i was like all right
and it's like all right well i had no
chance there and so i feel like it would
just it would require more teamwork if
that guy couldn't fire and that that is
a huge
uh that to me that the game mode just
doesn't feel good just on that alone it
creates so many 100 like i thought the
exact same thing especially when i saw
somebody zip and slam like i said
another thing i thought was kind of uh
weird too and and i could be wrong about
this i do need to log into d1 just to
confirm it but i thought in d1 it also
tracked the amount of kills people got
on top because
destiny 1 were
it was like a score based system so even
regular kills you just got like 100
points or whatever yeah exactly exactly
so yeah and this now and even if like
let's say it doesn't go towards the
score per se like it's not even on the
board at the end so it just it just felt
like there was the scoreboard
it kind of felt bare bones on that front
like i kind of wouldn't mind it kind of
what you were describing there scaro2
where you know to a certain degree it's
it's get kills and then also you know it
slam because then it gave you that
option too of kind of like the ketchup a
little bit yeah i don't know i think the
reason they stopped it is because a lot
of people in destiny 1 would take it and
then hide with the because if you if you
defended your spark runner you got more
points per kill yeah
would just take it to their spawn and
just camp on it maybe a timer isn't for
a long time
i don't have the answers but it does
have a timer i think it's like a minute
that you can hold it max
minute and a half okay see i haven't
even seen it that much but yeah i was
like there is the time but that's that's
a long time for one person to be able to
hold that thing if it was
i don't know
half of that maybe if it was half that
would be a little more urgent for you to
kind of rush and then you either got to
try and make a run for it or not um i'm
with you guys though it's like i haven't
seen the new map so again my feeling on
this is from the smaller maps
and from what i've seen is like
if you peek out one or two people say on
your team get popped quick then they
just can start pushing forward
knock you all down one person grabs a
spark and then i've seen p i've not
respawned and the spark's been dunked
it's been that fast that they can just
literally march through if you get like
the bad lobby balance on the team and
i've done everything in freelance and i
don't know how stacks are but that's the
first couple matches i had were awful i
was like oh god what have i walked into
and then i have i played a little bit
yesterday and i had one actually go to
sudden death i finally did experience
the
i script finally see that one um that
was actually kind of cool i liked that
that it was reset there's three you're
like all right this is gonna be chaos
see what happens i like that if it gets
there
um i did have one match where it
actually felt back and forth where there
was like here's the guy picking it up
it's like okay you see it and you go
over there it's like oh he dropped it
okay so everybody runs over there he
picks it up tries to go with it and it
was just this little like cat and mouse
game running around the entire match for
a little while and actually like i like
that there was you know the point to go
for the objective somebody tries to run
it and you don't see where it's at
forever so like if you say you're going
one direction then you backtrack the
other like as you were saying you could
go around but of course as i think you
guys are saying if you are sword skating
and i was trying to even catch a guy who
ran
i saw him going in banner following the
middle area go down like not where
usually the heavy spawns in the middle
but the far side i saw him going outside
like by the
the paddy like the
balcony area go outside and beat me to
the rift and i had the inside track
because he was freaking dashing all the
way through the whole way just beat me
before i could even cover the ground i
was like how the hell did you get there
so fast so yeah the idea of like if you
had to be a little bit more grounded and
you couldn't do anything more than like
say
primary weapons or something like that
to defend yourself yeah something on
that does need to change i agree
teddy we shoot those on it man
all right
buckle up oh because story time
everybody it's teddy story i i i think i
can confidently say that i probably the
most iron banner out of all of us here
because i'm about to get that title yeah
tomorrow
yeah i saw you your progress okay
so i love rifton d1 it definitely had
problems uh and
i'm glad they finally brought it back
here's my theory and i'm going to give
you the thesis first and i'm going to
explain it we're getting a dissertation
i think i think
i'm not that smart i think
uh that rift was brought back into the
game
through iron banner rather than labs so
they could get more data to test it okay
i have nothing to back this up other
than just some nuances and like
it just feels not polished like it's not
that bungee level of of polish
especially because it's an established
thing it's not even a new thing it's
something that already exists so
when they redid gambit last season
they were attempting to solve all these
different problems that players over
time had figured out how to abuse
mechanics or
the way players played and had this data
to back this up and so in a vacuum all
these changes on paper
were good but collectively it made the
experience pretty negative for gambit i
think most people agree with that and i
think rift suffers from the same problem
there are all these little things in d1
and probably things are trying to be
proactive as well with the transition g2
because they're so much more powerful
that
uh
individually they're good changes but
collectively they're not um
we touched on this earlier but one of
the big problems is that i figured out
within a few hours of playing where
exactly i can stand so that they don't
spawn in their main spawn they'll start
spawning in the middle of the map and
then my team can just literally walk up
and dunk the spark
and that that is just not okay like i'd
rather be spawn killed in my spawn
because at least then i have a chance to
shoot the person that's running at the
thing as travis alluded to or i think he
explicitly said it if you spawn in the
middle of the map that's it like you're
not you're not making it to get them uh
and that sucks
um the respawn timer is definitely too
long
i think if you're the attacking team
like if your team has the spark uh one
solution that i've seen proposed and
that i kind of like is that your respawn
timer should be longer and if you're the
defending team it should be shorter but
you should also have the option to
respawn uh quicker than the timer for
revive so kind of like d1 had this in
some game modes where you had the option
to revive uh yourself but then people
think that i think that was skirmish
right
yeah yeah yeah
because i think it's what 12 12 seconds
or 11 seconds uh you have to wait to
respawn and that's just that's just a
long time and i'm sure they'll dial that
in and they'll they'll figure it out but
so uh to give you a little data i played
primarily in a six stack i did freelance
a little bit um half of my six stacking
was with lfg people no comms the other
half was with friends and uh most of the
time we were 5-0 or 5-1 it was pretty
rare that we lost my fastest game i
finished with 6 minutes and 50 seconds
left on the clock so i think it was
approximately three three minutes of
actual gameplay um
the
i think shoulder charge is a bigger
problem than eager's edge the eager's
edge is definitely uh like good but you
have to have ammo for that and that's
true heavy ammo responds really
awkwardly sometimes but like shoulder
charge
you have that up until you use it so
i've seen people pick up the spark in 10
seconds later it's dunked without even
the team getting there
um overall though i do like the mode it
just has some weird
weird issues
that i think the iron banner beta phase
right uh the round thing
so so do you think that iron banner labs
is almost like a lap before they make it
a full mode do you think eventually rift
won't live just an iron banner
yeah well i mean they said that they
said it will be open so what i'm saying
but do you think that's the plan like
yes like so
i think they just didn't want to put the
labs label on it because people tend not
to play the labs version i have nothing
to back that up but that just
anecdotally people tend to not
participate in that so by putting an
iron banner this big event that
everybody plays it's the second week you
get more data more people participating
um
some of the bugs are really unfortunate
specifically the one where your rep gets
capped i'm really glad i avoided that
because if i didn't the double reset
would have been like a nightmare uh
otherwise it only took me like 10 hours
to do it mostly winning obviously so
it's quicker but um i saw people do it
solo and it's not
not terribly bad
um
something else oh the round thing i i
get why they did the reset
uh
i don't like the black screen i think
there needs to be some
something you know score or something i
legitimately thought my game crashed the
first time it happened
it would be nice that worked but how
many times i've been sent to the
dashboard on xbox with
with with this you know how many bugs
this joint got from i don't know have
you experienced that like i've been
getting crashes all the time like hard
crashes to the dashboard
it's called season of the haunted car
[Laughter]
the last thing i want to get on is the
round thing because i think it's the
most significant change to the game mode
i totally understand why they did this
because in d1 there definitely was a
snowball effect if you had a confident
team where you could just spawn trap
them and and i get that however other
game modes like headquarters and call of
duty and i think maybe even halo had a
similar thing i have a pretty good
system for this where there's like a 30
second lull kind of where
uh the positioning of the spark would
change so and they already have that
because of the multi-spark thing so
rather than have it in this in the
center which only has a 15 second
cooldown or 10 second cooldown to start
spawn somewhere else so that way your
teams kind of can regroup and that way
also people can spawn in different areas
and it's basically impossible to spawn
trap them because as it stands right now
with a competent team if you're spawning
in the middle of the map or if you're
covering the middle of the map and their
spawn i can watch them spawn in front of
me and we'll spawn trap them um granted
you know that takes coordination but
yeah
you know but that's what they're trying
to solve rather than
breaking i get it um
the taking away of the score i think is
uh
the biggest mistake
uh like not that it invalidates people's
contributions but when you're playing in
a stack or even even individually
there's people they're going to slay
there's people they're going to play the
objective and you you kind of marry the
two to make the game mode work and
i mean
team wiping is another issue where if
you wipe uh you're pretty much free to
score but i'm sure they'll dial that in
so i i would like to see some like my
kills contribute to the game in some way
completely i
agree that uh whether it's either at the
end of this end of the game on the
scoreboard someone but i'd prefer to be
like an actual score in the game like d1
um
and yeah that's kind of my rant my two
cents on that it's it's the bones are
there they just they just need to tweak
it a little bit and i'm glad the iron
banner title isn't that ridiculous to
get it's yeah just a time it's just a
time since you should get it eventually
yeah um there's nothing crazy to try as
a triumph hunter i was really worried
that the pvp stuff would keep me alive
so i'm glad that's
okay so thank you i am a little upset
you can't guilt this season but you know
next season
okay so do you think that was because
they only you only have two weeks to do
it and they didn't want to have people
like burn themselves out or do you think
it's because the guild's not ready yet
or
i i think they're just spacing the
content out personally yeah i i really
tried to understand why they did two
weeks it seems kind of weird to me
because some season some seasons that
are the three month seasons have had
three iron banners some had a four
typically it's three and so it's a
little weird to me that they just cut
out a whole week especially you know
towards the end of the season there's
not a lot going on yeah
you're playing right and iron banner is
one of those things that brings people
back so it it was a little weird to me
to see that um
it could be a fomo thing uh yeah they're
they're leaning more into the events now
with the triumphs and the event pass
thing you got to buy so we haven't seen
that yet but
about that yeah
so maybe maybe it has something to do
with that they're not telling us but um
yeah it's
i really want it to be good but it's
just not the new map honestly it looks
aesthetically pleasing but it is just
not fun to play on uh for it it feels
like a halo map it really does it's just
not not great for destiny uh banner fall
and convergence i like them they're fine
they worked in d1 they work in this game
um yeah that's that's my my spiel
you gotta get your bars off there
yeah you gotta get the buzz
uh
my therapy you know yeah no you gotta
get it out that's that's why we have you
on every 20 we used to be over 21
episodes we probably broke down old for
a little bit but the egg broke street um
no i mean you guys have covered a lot of
it and i think a lot of them are good
points for me like the respawn it feels
bad if a couple people die didn't like
the six steam roll you and then i'm just
sitting there waiting to respawn no
one's reviving me and then all of a
sudden like i'm still dead and they
don't i'm like i didn't have
literally no chance
i was like that doesn't feel wonderful
but then on the other side i had the
matches that were
i had that one that was like two to one
like went to time going back and forth
like that actually felt good and that
was actually a bannerfall of all maps
like somehow we had like the the free
the freelance group that were probably
like lower on the skilled match because
nobody was like sword skating around
it's like all right everybody bundle up
okay now we all died okay everybody it
was like it felt kind of like it
probably is intended to feel because
people weren't abusing too many
mechanics it's kind of the way i feel
like gambit could be if it was like
whenever we saw them do the gambit
tournament with whatever set loadouts
they had before it ever released when
they kind of did that online like
tournament 6v6 when they played or for
however many they did when they did that
online stream to like promo it before
that actually looked cool but now that
we have all the you know galahore and
everything else just abuses that same
thing probably i feel like in here
if it is just like not quite being
abused this bad actually has some fun
back and forth a little push and pull
but when you get into
you know get steamrolled then you can't
even respawn fast enough somebody's
sword skating across the map or shoulder
charging and all those things come into
it you're like it needs a little bit of
tweaks and again yeah i'm with you guys
like the black screen scorecard feels
good that type of like would be good
that type of stuff so it needs something
some love i only ever saw one person
eager edging with with the with the
spark it was mostly shoulder well i
didn't see that too often either but
shoulder charge was more prevalent than
you got showers again you have to get
ammo yeah for it but but it is a problem
for sure or at least i'm at a higher
level obviously yeah uh i think on paper
they want it to be this tug of war game
and
it does that on paper but then like i
said once once you get into the
nitty-gritty of it it's just really not
how it plays
uh which is unfortunate because again i
think it's a good game mode it's just
but they'll get it they they did it with
trials and they'll do with this it just
might take them
time it's unfortunate that it wouldn't
launch
polished or what we're used to
we got iron banner iron banana we kind
of got iron banana we got a little bit
of a beta phase we got to work through a
few kinks you got to get to get
underneath it a little bit oh i didn't
mention this the new reward system is
like fantastic um right right before we
got on this i turned in my 30 engrams
that i got for the double reset
it's just like trials and so it's
it's great like it's really awesome that
i can just focus on one thing for them
all the prices store man yeah that's
good
six thousand shards so
yeah you literally show us all right
yeah
but i
much or if you're not doing understand
of the exploits that have come up over
the last couple years to get shards it
definitely is it's a pricey choice to
make so
um
yeah
what about you guys what do you guys all
think where you guys at on
yeah i mean you talk about just the the
the salad and what is this new system
yeah rewards game mode yeah i mean do
you think two times a season is weird i
know we've got him in the middle where
eve lavonte would be so they would be
duking it out over space because they
moved him down off his little balcony up
there but yeah it's like it is weird
that it's two and it feels like if
solstice is in july and we've got
august seems like it's gonna be
i don't know what's gonna be in august
it feels like right now and iron banner
feels like it would fit perfectly there
because if salsas is about three weeks
and there's some down time in there i
see no reason not to put one there so it
is weird that they have these two
pre-solstice which is on like july 9th
and then august is going to be just a
ghost town i think before we get that
next season so it is odd time personally
yeah it's our time and i i i think with
teddy it almost did it's still getting
dated it almost does feel like it's a
work in progress or certain things but
look i like it it's back it's an
objective team mode i've always been a
fan of that as opposed to just layout
it's a good change of pace you know with
um saline in the system he needed he
needed an upgrade
i think from the mode itself i just want
to ask
cb like from d1 because i don't remember
did they tell you
like they give you now this written q
you know spark runners far imminent was
that there before it's been so long i
just don't remember was that there
i think it was or or they might have
phrases
differently but i think it was similar
yeah okay i like that
i like the sound cue when you know
they're getting close you know what i'm
saying it adds a little tension to it
you know the same kind of thing look
it's a decent mode it's fun you just got
to make a couple tweets and um yeah i
think my overall thing was i was just
dreading because you know lord cognito
gotta have that ironwood title so i was
just dreading what are they gonna put me
through because i really don't title
surf like i don't go if i don't hunt
like my man teddy you know say so i was
curious and i was like oh this is
actually reasonable this is just like
really play and commit it wasn't nothing
crazy so i'm going to get it done
honestly the worst part about it is just
making sure you don't get the bug where
your rep uh gets really low right
make sure i wear the the armor suits and
the emblem for the extra armor yeah four
challenges don't go over four challenges
okay yeah other than that like you're
it's it's really not if you're stacking
with people it's not that bad okay or
challenges what do you mean
if you do fortunately on one character
you'll do one a day but people have been
doing it on all characters and all of a
sudden they had like five of four weekly
challenges
and it bugged out so instead of getting
you know they were showing like 13 times
the rep they were supposed to be getting
but they were getting like
66 a match or something that would take
them forever so they went over and it
broke the math
wow jesus
yeah yeah that's honestly the worst like
as if you can get past that and make
sure you don't bug that out you're good
like it's just just commit the time and
you're you'll get it yeah especially
after tomorrow's reset you'll have the
fourth one so just you know play
something this weekend it'll be the
fastest
rep for the uh the emblem i need to put
that on
emblem
when you start up iron banner uh travis
if you there's a like where the buffs
would be in pve if you hover over it it
shows you all the buffs you can get and
what you currently have
yeah nice and it shows you your current
multiplier as well which is nice nice
that is a little inaccurate though
because so so i'm at a um the max you
can get is 11 if you do all the
challenges and uh all armor and emblem
which means i should be getting around
like 700 something rep but i think on a
five streak i was getting like
330 something
so okay
something's funky it's still high but
you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah well what's my feeling well so
i wanted to end on this wonderful one
we're two weeks into the season so i
know it's a little bit early but this is
the first time we've had a dungeon key
so we know that we actually figured out
that was 20 bucks
uh covers this dungeon covers the one in
season 19 and then this season and i
wanted to ask you guys for somebody out
there who may listen to this and be like
hey is this worth it what do you guys
think do you think the dungeon key by
itself is worth it and do you think
season of the haunted is worth the
purchase
i can start
i've been doing a lot of dungeon help
and this is actually one of my most
frequent questions i get it all the time
and at least with me i mean especially
coming from a like a development side of
it um
so it's ten dollars per dungeon right we
have this one and we have another one
season 19.
i spent more for my taco bell yesterday
i
i i can never enjoy it again i'm i'm i'm
realistically i mean i was playing
shattered yesterday i'm realistically
gonna be playing this in two years like
there's just not that many things that i
can spend ten dollars for and still be
enjoying two years from now like instead
or even be able to experience again like
in the sense of like let's just use
another example movies are getting so
expensive these days go in the movie
theater especially those recliner chairs
20 for the movie and then after i've
watched it it's not like i get to go
home and i can come back to the theater
the next day i'm like oh yeah yeah i
spent the twenty dollars let me go watch
the movie again they're like nah like
where's that you know
yeah
yeah subscribe to hbo buy the blu-ray
buy whatever peacock whatever you know
or go buy the movie again and sit back
in your recliner chair again like for me
it's like
i mean i i just there's so many other
things we spend money on that that uh
that we we never can touch again there's
so many things legit yesterday when i
was doing dungeon up i went and got some
jalapeno poppers i wish i could teleport
those back from yesterday and eat them
again i can't they're gone
there's so many there's so many things
that we we spend money on that we
experience so shortly and then it's gone
but for some reason like with with
gaming it seems like that's like kind of
lost um for me personally the
development costs money i i maybe i'm
biased i've been a developer for a while
it's like i just feel like i mean for
ten dollars there's some there's this is
one of the best ten dollars i could buy
i mean it's kept me already
you know uh more engaged than most
things i spend ten dollars on in my
daily life do and that's just this is
personally it's just i don't know
there's not a lot of ten dollar things
and so if people can give me examples
it'd be great but i just don't have that
many things
i don't have that many things right now
ten dollars then yeah this dungeon's
cheaper than a gallon of milk or a
gallon of gas apparently yeah and
true yeah sorry i just i just can't get
multiple enjoyment out of things that i
usually spend for that price and for me
um you know with my time uh i i think 10
is fine you know whatever skipped
my jalapeno poppers once
i'll be i'll be i'll be okay
here's what i tell people shadows look
like he's bubbly yeah
uh i hate this question
okay i hate it uh and the reason i hate
it is because a
money means different things to
different people
you definitely shouldn't buy it because
you're not you know you should be
spending the money on something else
probably and and two it doesn't speak to
the qualitative properties of the game
people like to say like oh travis you're
being so hard on this game it's only ten
dollars it's like okay but it's price
does not at all affect how good of a
game it is right and so my my i always
try to focus on is the game good how
good is it how not good is it etc what
are its pros and cons not is it worth
the money because to me the money is
separate there are some free games that
are better than destiny seasonal haunted
apex legends is one of them you go play
that game for free you don't have to
spend any money on it right so
once we start getting into is the money
worth it i kind of just go yes i only
want to i want to talk about it for for
me it's worth it for my current
financial situation and the fact that i
enjoy destiny but it's such a hard
question to just like broadcast that's
the answer if you're a child and you get
dollars allowance a year or whatever
probably not uh you know save it maybe
uh but yeah it just really depends on
what your situation is and uh
i'll answer the question that i want to
answer which is is it good and my answer
would be uh just the dungeon just the
season pass what are we doing i think
we're doing the dungeon right now
i'm sorry
i would say if i answered it at your
version i'd say it's good if i'm
switching mine out
anyone we haven't seen
so this dungeon one we haven't seen i'll
say having only seen fifty percent of it
it's sitting at maybe a seven out of ten
good good not great that's my that's my
uh okay if i answer in that standpoint
then i'm at least i think closer to like
i'd say probably
i take them closer to nine right now at
least currently but that might be
recency so i maybe i'll say 8.5 and see
how i'm feeling in a month
um but i think i'll start off with an
8.5 basis tonight somewhere in between
everybody else
sam yeah i think i i think uh you'd have
to
jack the price up quite high for to
reach a part where i'd be like uh no i'm
not paying for it
i mean for us it's also a tax write-off
right
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah
of course i
if i've spent 10 bucks for a season pass
for some dumb cosmetics i'll never use
[ __ ] yeah i'll drop 10 bucks for a
dungeon like
hell yeah you know so okay fine travis
had a better way to go about it give it
a give it that you know one out of 10
rating yeah uh same as cb 8.59
well with the asterix of uh plus or
minus one for recency bias yeah yeah
we'll come back to it a month and see
yeah yeah yeah that's a good point ready
uh we're just in the dungeon right now
yeah this is a pass yeah
yeah
that's it's about an eight um
i
i think a lot of it always boils down to
how you value replayability
um
obviously everyone when it comes to
money like travis said i was thinking
the same thing value is defined
differently for everyone so it's a hard
it's a hard answer question to answer or
everyone answer it differently but in
terms of gameplay i think it's it's it's
good um
but there's a lot of players that
play the dungeon once play the dungeon
twice and they're done and to them you
know once they've seen it that's it and
then there's people like us that are
gonna grind it forever and
uh get the best possible role or
whatever it is uh get all the triumphs
you know and so to me yeah of course
it's worth ten dollars because
you know i'll play it a hundred times um
but yeah it's just good um
i i have different problems with the
pricing structure which we've talked
about ad nauseam
multiple pricing structures yeah
when we get to the season pass uh i have
a lot to say so you know but yeah give
it an eight i think i think it's it's
good
god
yeah i mean in agreement with uh teddy
just it's an eight it's a day it's it's
very solid if it's just the dungeon
itself with the thought of another one
coming with the key right um that's good
this is great value you know the
dungeons are some of the best in-game
content in destiny i don't think the
designers get enough credit the devs
don't get enough credit for the work and
here's the thing i i know we we we give
them a lot of thing
but it's hard to satiate a community
that is seen as much as we've seen and
has played as long as we played and they
keep us satisfied
i have to give them credit cause i'm
thinking about love i got to make a game
and i got this group that is very
temperamental and very like yo we see
that already like oh come on you did
that you brought that like like that's
really disheartening like if you really
a dev like i could understand it and i
always give them
props for creativity i feel uh weapon
design
for the most part and feel second to
none the way the game looks
aesthetically
and i don't think the narrative team
like look i remember e we this one this
was flashpoint
we used to be like yo this story they
got a great story and it's like why is
it trapped in grimoire and why is it and
we're at a point now where i think we're
a little selfishly
like comfortable with how good the story
is now like it was never this good like
people used to clown me like that she
has no story as no lord like what are
you talking about and now you can safely
say that when you play a dungeon
and i'm getting the narrative bits and
i'm actually caring about kallus and how
he feels and stuff like that so that's
where i'm at with i think you know the
content itself from a dungeon standpoint
it's great it's eight i think the next
one's probably gonna be great as well so
i'm not even worried about it now if
we're talking
about season of the haunted
comparatively to other seasons
that's where my score gonna be low you
know but as far as the dungeon yes this
is great solid content i think they they
pretty much knocked it out apart even
with recency bias i i felt i was like
this this feels fun when i'm playing
this dude i like what i'm playing i'm
enjoying this i give it a seven
because i've lived outside of the bubble
of destiny probably more than most
people on this panel and uh i i just i
can't get over some of the old stuff
they keep doing
all the stuff
like champions like the fact that we
still don't have lucent hive or some
sort of new end game type enemy that
stuff just bothers me but everything
that they did that you expect i like
that's fair that's fair i mean you being
you in alignment with lucid hive and how
they changed the game and that true
threat no you know me and you we didn't
i think everyone ever every destiny
hardcore i think is over champions
for an hour so yeah yeah they keep
putting that stuff out where you're at
is like where we being your line is the
witch queen really set the bar
with the mechanical change that fear and
then go get the ghost put yourself in
harm's way cr that fundamentally change
how destiny's played and it's just going
to be interesting now for them to try to
do it again without being bound to the
narrative lucid hive right how are they
going to you know say like you know if
that's a challenge they're going to have
to figure out but
yeah
is it worth it well just wait before he
goes if it's okay yeah before like to
that point i mean there are brand new
engine enemies introduced in this
dungeon i have never feared a
non-sentient backpack so much in my
entire life i don't know exactly what
you're talking about
can i give you guys a piece of advice on
that now i know it's not the most
efficient thing everybody goes in with
the lament slashes them to death and
he's done it's totally fine have one
person
use xenophage on all those guys and that
stuff blows up and you never have to
worry about it even even easier don't
even use the heavy just use our polish
one shot vomit just
and was on that part of the fight and
all of a sudden i'm like why did i and
you see the little thing up in the top
corner and you're like you're not even a
guy you're just this thing on the floor
and it's like half the time when they're
on the ground they explode and half time
they don't like if you deliberately
shoot them it's like sometimes they'll
explode and sometimes they won't and
it's just like ah the accidental
teleports are so brutal too with
something too close to the belt
literally you sneeze on it next time
wave frame
but tractor cannon won't like if you're
doing the the titan hammer build the
tanks like the hammer you can throw it
at it doesn't do a damn thing yeah it
doesn't
if the hammer is next to it and it blows
up that will set it up
[Laughter]
like yeah it was like when you go to
break the chains for the guys if some of
the
shielded guys are walking around you hit
those in the shield explosion i feel
like that sets off the chains and sends
me into a damage phase before i'm ready
so there's you got to be very particular
with when you get ready to do certain
things of where you're going around but
it is
it's it's very fun and i enjoy it but
also there are moments when you're
looking at a guy
or you're looking and there's nobody
there and all of a sudden it's teleport
or they teleport away and you're just
going all right something's still not
quite right here
yeah some of the teleports of the
enemies are showing as you guys have
said and we've said it for a while it's
like it's just showing to where it's
either net or code or backhand something
is just like i'm looking at and now he's
over here i'm like
no
and then the fact that yeah it's just
there's a couple moments like that and i
was playing
with a couple guys earlier but it's the
point where you're sitting on the little
platform
and you're like okay i'm on the right
one and then it resets you back to the
front you're like hold on i gotta
reorientate the room and you're not
quite sure where you were before so a
couple weird bugs and stuff will throw
off but overall it's like i'm having a
blast in it i will solo it also
flawlessly i almost actually wasn't too
far from that earlier it's definitely
doable like i'm 1272 1271 not that high
it's definitely doable master more power
that'll take me a little while to put a
group together for that one but
i'm enjoying it yeah i was like i think
it's worth the value these things always
are easily probably some of my favorite
content because they're built to be
sold-able you can definitely and this
one especially as you guys said we got
dungeon weapons and i gotta save these
weapons oh aesthetic
the look of the weapons is fantastic as
you said we got a brand new linear type
i got a
feeding frenzy rampage of the void smg
like that was my first drop so i'm just
like
go ahead and lock you and save you in
the vault uh and then i got the pulse
rifle and it's absolute trash so that
made up what's the pulse what's the
pulse that's the type of stasis
it's the one that can get desperado
yeah
it can be good it could be decent
my
and it's nice and then couple it with
that intrinsic origin perk that if you
get damaged the reload is faster well it
can it can roll with uh auto loading as
well so yeah and show clip yeah that's
that's what i really can call it chill
clip yeah chill clear auto loading
blinding yeah
that's that's the rule this
is this conversation just reminded me of
something that i think is really strange
and we you know we're talking about the
prices we would pay for the season and
what it is and stuff and one thing that
we didn't discuss and i haven't heard
anybody discuss is the fact that
nightmare containment the seasonal event
is free for everyone oh i didn't realize
how far it was yeah so it's like you're
when you buy the season you're paying
for the season pass and the sever
missions and i think that's it
really yeah it's solar 3.0 for everybody
too right yeah yeah solar three points
that is a good question so what the 100
volt spaces are for everybody so
later i mean if you're going to buy it
it sounds like if you're going to play
destiny for over the course of the
coming year at all the 40 deluxe has
been far worth it it has the dungeons in
there it has the seasons and that's why
again it's like you gotta figure out
what 40 dollars is but if you're gonna
play this game over the course of an
entire year and put hundreds of hours in
or however much even if you play a few
days like a few hours a weekend that's
still going to be 100 hours over the
course of a year as you guys were
talking about a movie's 20 bucks for two
hours so
all of those numerical values again you
got to figure out what's worth it but
that is the idea if there is any
foresight to it they
they do steer you into the bundle but
the bundle for what you get in there is
actually a very good value depending on
you know when you start breaking things
apart it tends not to be but if you do
the bundle it is actually quite quite
good
sounds like you just get the season pass
though at this point
you're definitely right i'm with you so
yeah breaking it down you're right like
i feel like if you don't get them all
together it is kind of
yeah
it's a little more bare bones
individually yeah
that kind of makes my
my take or my stance even a little more
jaded because
this season to me kind of sets a really
bad precedent of
you can charge ten dollars for a thing
that we had previously and we if we just
change it a little bit well that's why i
think i think that's kind of the theory
of why they didn't charge for it why it
is free because they've previously
expanded now yeah they've gone on record
saying anything that's coming back from
the dcv destiny 2 or destiny 1 will not
you want to pay for okay so
like the whole leviathan patrol zone
that's free anyone can access that the
nightmare containment which is on it
anyone can access that okay it's free
okay you're basically paying for the
story
yeah that's it can you get the seasonal
weapons without the season pass so i'm
not talking about
are those available you can get the
menagerie ones for free you cannot get
the the six brand news okay so so you
could get awestringer for free at the
moment right yes yes and then beloved in
all of those but you can't you can't get
like that new trace rifle on the rocket
and like all those correct yeah yeah no
not the new glaive not the new
or scout or whatever the hell that's a
good one
gotcha okay yeah yeah i've been dealing
with it every time scaroa have you been
dealing with it too
it's really annoying because it's it's
the same name so it seems like it should
be really easy i i i talked to my
youtube manager yesterday they're
they're trying to do like at least from
what i've heard they're trying to to i
either recommend that they need to have
um
like you know we have the banned words
filter in the community actually banned
words for um account names yeah yeah or
they need they need to have some sort of
um approval for names have you guys have
you guys tried just going to their
channel and commenting on this stuff
yesterday i put things in sub only and
then the bots started seven
i've had my chat and sub only for the
better part of the year because of that
it's so frustrating yeah and it's um
yesterday when i was in like or two days
ago it was they weren't even all these
that you guys are saying was just all
racial stuff it was just fresh it's just
frustrating
really
wait wait we just jumped over to twitch
i just was tired of it yeah and it's
it's the longer your stream goes the
more frequently exactly yeah
it gets into the jump rope towards the
end of our phone
hopefully they'll get on it soon yeah
yeah hopefully it's been a problem for
years honestly exactly
yeah
but they used to be in the comment
though is the difference remember
we were streaming back in the day it was
easy to get them because you know we
just we just
do the word filter but now they've
gotten a little smarter i used to filter
emojis because of that same same thing
yeah they're evolving they're becoming
shittier and it's even when you ban them
they're stupid they're stupid
he literally has the word [ __ ] in his
name
that doesn't i don't know trust me i'm
with you i'm trust me i am so good
youtube hopefully gets there and again
if youtube can actually get there and
rival twitch we'll see but
or you know
maybe we should check out what what they
got
that's your next review
travis comes back one out of ten
oh my god
well so when your computer is uh ridden
with viruses and different things i know
a guy that you can hit up and uh
[Music]
well
this is our last episode before gcx um
very excited for gcx scarole sorry you
are not going to be there but definitely
look forward to uh next year yeah we
will definitely go next year
this year it should be a ton of fun um
if you are going to gcx
look for any of us obviously uh i'll be
wearing an ibanta shirt i'm having a
couple of them made for me
um
you're gonna find thai guy travis in a
suit because he doesn't like the destiny
ties just so yeah okay
can you wear your own merch is that
allowed no that's how i knew e was e
when i said yeah i literally like sure
because because me eating before your
cheeto
[Laughter]
i think we met before i ever was on the
podcast i think yeah
i've grown some but i was like i'm not
nearly as big as you guys anyway but
it's like
i didn't know that many people so i was
like i put ibontis right on my shirt so
if somebody's like oh i've seen that
like they a couple recognized me that
like a couple people recognize me that
way but it's like i got ibontas on the
front and the last word on the back so
because we gotta wear masks too
yeah so i was like all right so i'm just
gonna label me
that's all i was doing
it worked last time so yeah no it didn't
i remember too the reason i knew you he
was remember uh those like first like
whisper videos like because like how
much was
those things popped completely off i was
like who's this guy let me go check them
out so fast
my that was this video if i ever get a
video that big again i will be ecstatic
because that one is
it's really weird because for all three
of us whispering
it was just it wasn't working
whisper did a whole lot and it was funny
scary because i was um because it was
funny the day it came out after all the
looking for it somewhere every day i was
looking for it but then the day it was
out i was actually um on a work thing in
richmond so i had you up when you were
going through it on the day and i was so
jealous i was like what would it be
it looked so funny i was just like i
remember like because i was i didn't get
to play it to that weekend i would think
it was sunday sorry
100 is not the same
yeah so yeah that is where we will be
next week uh travis [ __ ] and i might try
and record a actual live episode that is
the goal is to have 200 officially be a
week later but it's going to be our live
one
what day are you guys getting there i'm
going to be here wednesday evening what
day is that number was i'll be there the
eighth so i just don't know what day
that is
the same day yeah yeah perfect yeah i'll
be i'll be there eight i'll be the
eighth okay yeah so i was like trouble i
need to make a giant discord group or
just dms and stuff like if you're there
hit me up or attack me or something but
yeah i'll be there wednesday thursday
will be a chill day kind of stuff like
yeah and then friday more and more
people will be showing up so
nice
nice all right well you guys have
anything else that you want to drop
while you're here on the show for this
week at least before we kind of wrap
things up
anybody got anything else nobody talk at
once cool okay all right
no but it's like as we outro um i just
want to say thank all three of you
gentlemen for showing up today is
absolute pleasure to get everybody's
takes and i had an absolute blast with
this might try and do a bigger group
occasionally more often because this was
a lot of fun this was fun
yeah definitely a blast so at this point
the table is or the floor i should say
is yours um
cb if you want to go first just let
everybody know where to find you what
you've been doing and what you got
cooking
um
same place most part um youtube
cb gray twitch same thing um
i've been streaming a lot more lately
i've had a little more time to uh to
kind of uh focus on the channel so
definitely we'll be doing as much help
as we can as we can and you know just
enjoying new things as they come and
just hanging out um
i'll be at guardian conf and you guys
gonna be there i'd love to see you all
and other than that just keep supporting
these amazing guys
cb or scarole
uh scaro9 youtube twitter
yeah that's that's good good stuff
how are scarro one through eight doing
i actually i had to kill them it's like
a ritualistic sacrificing i like look i
grew up in there they were like six huh
no it's different than that it's like um
jet li movie one you can kill the other
one
yes yeah
so i grew up in like the boonies right
the deep south and we had this like cult
thing and it was like you have to you
have to kill your siblings
you were in the far cry 5 cult got it
yeah yeah yeah exactly right so um
somebody says the scream said it's like
highlander
there could be only one stero 9 is the
one that survived yes
scare the best and uh
of the scaros
or every i don't know and uh
yeah man i don't know i'm excited i got
things i'm excited for but nothing i'm
doing you know uh
cool music coming out motionless white
has a new album tomorrow it's fantastic
nice
if you want some some some music follows
go follow this guy
yeah if you like metal because i i'm an
elitist about that if you like country
[ __ ] off
[Laughter]
man nothing pisses me off then more than
loud country music i can't stand it
makes me shudder
our crunchy numbers are sinking right
now we gotta save the show
what about quiet metal music
that's funny that no i like i like like
ambient stuff it's fine whatever just
everything about the country i'm sure
everything
just plays because you don't like loud
country specifically oh like quiet
country
quiet country no that's worse than no
that's called that's
that's that's nickelback okay so here we
go elevator music elevator music country
elevator music that's not even okay just
that i'm just trying to better music
i'll stand with that yeah yeah like what
hey look we got another one they're back
yeah
then we're in oh oh okay where is
if they just send me an email and they
were like hey would can we would you do
an ad read i'd do it like you know
i think these guys have something on the
ign home page i'm pretty sure all right
i'm done here like that's the main
banner across the top of the website
oh man dude i would i'd take it whatever
i've turned down like all sorts of ad
stuff do you guys get those uh
advertisements from the silver people
yeah
i don't know
there's people back like go away you
know yeah i've put it on like the thing
that's supposed to not be able to get
through the send but they get through
like they're supposed to go to spam and
they still get that email and i get the
um
dot cz
yeah exactly and then i get all the ones
for the recups too and they're like
80 of our business they're sherpas we
only do 20 recups now and it's like wow
you guys are only 20 [ __ ] and then
80
also [ __ ] for charging people for
running them through content like get
the hell out of here dude i'm just
savages so if if if naked dash hd
offered to promote at least i like i
support sex work that's fine
i would totally do an ad
my next time review account i make for
him nice okay
just trying to just trying to promote my
youtube account if you can follow that
good luck
yeah i got i got nothing
you can follow me at teasing teddy on
twitter i'm usually just trolling
friends and co-workers and then pulling
my hair out when i'm getting max triumph
score because i'm
oh are you a match scorer oh yeah are
you two yeah
here i was actually gonna bring this up
and then i we got sidetracked and then i
okay
let's go let's go so so getting max trim
score has kind of been this chore now
for a while sure it's the same as you
probably know it's the same kind of i
think last time i checked before the
season was 94 people that have gotten it
but yeah i don't i don't think they
really communicate with each other so i
want to set up a way that we could also
i mean i'm in a clan of
like 20 30 people with mac shrine square
so
okay how do i how do i play with you
guys because
because i just i just need like-minded
people because i love my friends and i
love my clients
shoot me a discord invite and i'll
invite you to the server we have we have
triumph discord set up dog i just need
like-minded people who are we got real
illuminati there you go like if you
don't have max tram score i have a
discord server room
people who do
that's all we do we just we kind of we
kind of watch them post about max
triumph score and then we just kind of
comment on it and go dude no life touch
crosstalk okay hey hey travis how does
this make you feel
oh what is
makes me feel sorry for you
don't feel bad i also own all of them
like so
it's fine
dude i'll say this about you you guys
are great at supporting charities
great there we go positive spin there we
go
dude yeah uh but for for sure shoot me
uh discord invite and i'll get you in
all the servers oh my god
i thought i was just alone i was just
one one of 94 being like this is it like
i'm gonna die or i'm gonna get it
dude there's dozens
this is the culmination this is the
culmination of the podcast right here we
put scaro and teddy together
after the podcast but i i have watched
some of your videos and the only videos
i've watched from you are the ones where
you go on the chinese websites to get
those crazy envelopes because you have
the cleanest videos on what to click on
or what not to click on and that's where
i know you
hey dude don't take it i mean
yeah those videos are so much better
than i know i mean no no disrespect to
anyone else but like yours are just so
much cleaner than everyone else's and
it's like all right i'm not gonna get
anything shady watching this video
oh man there's no weird spot no weird
sponsor sponsors in the scaros chat i
mean hell i mean
i have a sexy voice
hit me up
i'm
baby
the email right now
anyway
you can follow me teasing teddy i post
all the crazy triumph things i do and
one day it'll be over and i can exit
this room and go touch grass or whatever
the kids say these days so uh
congratulations on 200 episodes or 201
however you want to phrase it i think
that's that's incredible uh eventually
you'll surpass fire team chat and maybe
i can actually exist outside of this
like pseudo podcast space where uh the
collective conscious uh allows me to be
real so
thank you as always and uh
congratulations
love love
travis
yeah i was like
after all of that i'm just like
i think i think i'm still processing
that someone with max triumph score has
a wife but anyway um
[Laughter]
yeah go check out the end of this
episode teddy is actually like visually
happier right now
someone else has experienced my pain and
they're real
that's that's what i've learned today
yeah it's beautiful it's beautiful
anyway uh yeah um you can you can follow
me on twitter at ty guy travis if you
haven't done that already and you want
to see just my my trash takes
you can watch the big cast show i do uh
every sunday i have i have one in mind
today to make fun of dan but i'm not
gonna do it
so
um
uh and uh you can also join my discord
where you make fun of max triumph score
people and watch all my uh content on
ign.com got previews reviews coming up
uh next week for mario strikers and uh
that's it for me guys i will see you all
at gcx i'm looking very much forward my
first gcx voice i
could never go in the past because i had
to go cover e3 for the site and e3 is
not happening this year so e3 is dead
e3's dead
dead game
games
games
so yeah i'll be there and uh mcclunkey
and thanks for watching everyone the
legend
tiger
yeah you ain't already know what it is
listen
201 so to speak right
you know um let us podcast man it's just
fun it's just friends talking about what
we love with this this this this
fraternity where we're not in the vip
section of the fraternity at some but uh
it's it's love i love this show and to
see where it's going and once we had you
know travis on and taking it to the next
level but um yeah this one meant a lot
because again all three of you represent
you know kind of where we are where are
were and then also scarole for the name
i'm never gonna forget that like that
was so cool he was like yeah man
i was just looking at that because i was
curious and we made it to episode 49
with it before yes yeah i gave you guys
the name so you guys have gone four
times as long as we ever did so bro oh
yeah always love for that always love
for that nice cv man the the younger
you're you already know you're the young
legend you know what i'm saying seeing
you out here it's gonna be dope and
teddy man that's family daddy's family's
been there from the beginning and uh
it's cool and i'm excited to finally
meet
trav in the flesh give him a big hug
[Music]
that big so i'm guessing
i look like if slenderman got a day job
that's my uh aesthetic yeah
e you know where it started at brother
you know it's down there
16
2016 2016. outside in the damn parking
lot passing that
yup tampa heat
smoldering but it's gonna be fun yep
i'm excited man yeah y'all don't know me
lord cognito check out the finally duke
we got some great good episodes there
with uh the xbox two um i lost podcast
on sunday check that out it'll be a big
one do a prediction show of course on
launchinggaming.net the writers
everybody doing a lot of destiny content
good jobs good job guys good job and um
also of course i love the support i've
seen everybody to chat for the last word
it's really fun so salute
love
uh for me yeah thank you cb thank you
scarole teddy travis cognito thank you
everybody in chat and thank you for
everybody who's listened at any point
along the way this thing started in the
middle of uh
well you know curse of osiris the best
time to start anything destiny related
so we are a little crazy and we have
made it this far and
next week hopefully we will officially
record episode official 200. we wanted
to do that in person timing almost made
it but didn't quite so yes i mess with
the numbers but i'm looking forward to
it but thank you all of the legends for
joining us all the way across the way
but also for this group tonight this was
an absolute blast having you guys on
here you never quite know how a group of
friends is going to like mix up and i
think this one was like this is magical
it was it was good talks it wasn't we
had a lot of really good conversation i
feel like it's like a family reunion
also real quick
we got to shout out our brother amazed
for making the music video
she's showing out some big bucks for
that too that production
the production was crazy
sound production i imagine they like
their sound designers or they outsource
them out sound designers too and
it sounded great crisp it looked great
i would
kill to work with someone on on a
capacity like that yeah
like at the same time just creating
everything coordinating every single
thing like it animated it was it was top
tier it was tough too salute to amaze
yeah it was very good uh
yeah gigi's too amazed for doing that
and uh bungie you know i love how bungie
empowers creators like like supports
them builds them up you know this is
something that amaze can now put on his
professional resume and point to and
like he got he almost certainly got paid
for it and that's like good on bungie
for having the resources yeah and the
com the the willingness to do something
like that to bolster someone's career
while you know obviously supporting
their own product and stuff but
awesome stuff really cool stuff and it's
something that you only see from bungie
really so yeah yeah pretty awesome by
far the best community i'm going to die
on that sort with bungie
because of this game look what it was
how it's connected all of us on so many
levels yeah really cool stuff well don't
miss the episode on july 7th because
he'll be here
oh there
go before he
so i got you
i was like nah he we had him on the show
i've always liked kind of popped into
his uh streams and stuff he's
just honestly ultra nice dude great chat
and happy to see that for him and happy
to see the success for all of our guests
on the show so
thank you very much everybody we are
going to wrap this one up here so this
is going to be very unconnected but
we'll see how it goes
uh thank you guys very much for being
here for this journey and for this
episode it has been
the last word
[Music]